when it comes to popularity versus
screen time there may be no bigger
winner than Boba Fett for decades fans
have been fervently buying action
figures comics and novels featuring the
world's favorite Bounty Hunter sorry dog
people love fat even though he has about
four lines of dialogue in the entire
original trilogy before being knocked
into a giant Pit by a blind guy
because of his popularity and his
limited screen time it would be easy to
think that Boba Fett doesn't have any
hidden secrets however the truth is that
there's still plenty you probably don't
know about this mysterious character
from a galaxy far far away his first
real appearance most people know that
Boba Fett first appeared on the big
screen in The Empire Strikes Back no
matter what George Lucas did to the
special edition of A New Hope later on
the real Savvy fan may even be able to
tell you fed's first appearance on any
screen was drawing 1978 Star Wars
holiday special maybe I can help you I
am Boba Fett but neither of those are
actually the first time the public got
to see Boba Fett his first public
appearance was a few weeks earlier on
September 24 1978 at the San Anselmo
County Fair San Anselmo was the home of
Luca's film at the time and George Lucas
thoughts that taking part in the local
parade was a great idea while Fett
didn't engage in any pie eating contests
or hog calling assistant film director
Duane Dunham donned the sweaty costume
and signed autographs even though no one
actually knew who Boba Fett was yet all
white even before Boba Fett took his
unusual place in a local parade and a
terrible holiday special he'd been going
through some changes concept artist
Ralph McQueary had a ton of different
designs for Boba that he was testing out
ultimately settling on the Mandalorian
armor fans know and love today the
original suit was completely fabricated
and Screen tested except it was
completely Stormtrooper white sure he
still had a cool jet pack and Sinister
Visa but he was basically a bleached out
version of the green and red guy of
today why those original Armor Designs
were originally planned to be old
stormtrooper armor from an old regiment
which would have made him look like a
medieval Knight marching into war with
modern soldiers but you know in space as
plans for the film shifted and the lore
began to grow the armor became
Mandalorian that took a smaller role and
he finally got some much needed color
the big bad
according to an interview with
lucasfilm's first fan relations officer
Chris Miller Fett was originally going
to play a much larger role in the
trilogy which is why he had such a
prominent role in the holiday special at
one point he was even going to Eclipse
Darth Vader as the trilogy's biggest bad
guy
foreign
as George Lucas became increasingly
bored with space he rewrote Star Wars
from a dozen films down to three
compacted his entire second Trilogy
concept into Return of the Jedi and
threw Fett into a belching desert cloaca
taking action when Star Wars has an
action figure controversy and they
happen surprisingly often it usually
revolves around Leia's gold bikini or
too few Rave figures on the shelves but
the original Star Wars action figure
controversy stemmed from none other than
Boba Fett
I'm the best value Bounty Andrew in the
whole galaxy that's why you got the job
let's recap fed's first appearance was
at a County Fair his second appearance
was in the holiday special his third
appearance prior to the May 1980 release
of Empire Strikes Back was on the back
of Action Figure packaging as a mail
away figure when he still didn't have a
backstory just one problem the fat
figure was portrayed with a rocket
firing backpack Star Wars fans who were
basically the original turbo nerds were
pretty upset at not receiving the
action-packed fair today were promised
Kenna had produced some prototypes of
the full figure which have since become
the Holy Grail of Star Wars collectibles
but they were never released to the
public due to safety concerns after a
child choked on a missile from a
Battlestar Galactica toy Hasbro bought
Kenner in 2010 and finally made things
right when they released an actual
rocket firing Boba Fett as a male away
in their vintage collection finally
adult nerds everywhere got their fondest
wish death by action figure if they can
just figure it out without killing each
other just push push the button push I'm
pushing
good God
fed's many Origins attack of the Clones
made it absolutely clear that Boba Fett
is the unaltered clone of legendary
Bounty Hunter Jango Fett the prototype
for all of the Galaxy's clone troopers
unlike his helmeted clone Bros Boba is
raised personally by Django and
eventually takes his own place in the
Galaxy as a bounty hunter but even
before attack of the Clones the Star
Wars expanded universe had developed a
rich backstory for just about every
weirdo in every scene of Star Wars no
matter how irrelevant even ice cream
maker guy fun fact his name is willro
Hood he's a rebel hero he has his own
action figure he has a legion of fans
and in terms of screen time vs fan
fervor he just might beat out Boba Fett
anyway according to tales of the bounty
hunters a novel released in 1996 Boba
Fett's real name was Justin Muriel and
he's essentially an ex-cop from the
world known as Concord Dawn who's exiled
from the planet for killing his corrupt
Superior eventually he's taken in by the
mandalorians and becomes Boba Fett after
attack of the Clones however Jaster was
Rewritten to be a completely separate
character from Fett in the comic series
Django fed Open Seasons jazza Maria was
the leader of Mandalore and the guy who
took a young Django Fett under his wing
after Django's parents were murdered
occasionally though both Boba and Django
would use jaster's name as their own
kinda like an Intergalactic Rusty
Shackleford he survived a fight with
Vader the original trilogy implies that
Boba Fett and Darth Vader have a pretty
okay relationship but readers of Star
Wars comics over the years have
witnessed a rather Unforgettable side to
Vader and fed trying to All Out murder
each other sure they're mostly
non-canonical now but that doesn't mean
it's not fun to see first there's a
fight in Star Wars Tales number 11 where
Fete actually holds his own against
Vader in a lightsaber battle in a
Cantina Vader and Fett faced off once
again in Boba Fett enemy of the Empire
number four where the stakes were a bit
higher in truly bizarre Comics fashion
the two fight fight over the severed but
still talkative head of a
fortune-telling alien queen Boba Fett
has hired to retrieve the head in a box
but Vader wants it as a tool for his
eventual overthrow of Emperor Palpatine
the two come to blows with Vader
deflecting Blaster bolts and cutting fed
getaway speeder in half until he stops
screwing around and force chokes fat who
kicks the head off a cliff and jet packs
to safety while Vader uses the force to
retrieve it with the two lonely ended up
having a pleasant work relationship
later on because a decapitated Queen
heads says they will and Vader is pretty
superstitious but they probably also
bonded over how difficult it is to go to
the bathroom while wearing armor eggs is
enough you'd think that Darth Vader
would have taken the record for the most
actors portraying the same character on
the big screen between actors last
second stand-ins and voice actors not to
mention stuntman but Boba Fett really
wins that award since for the most part
whoever fit into the armor got to play
him Jeremy Bullock played Fett through
most of the characters appearances in
the original trilogy with the exception
of two days when he missed filming and
the actor who played the rebel Pilot's
Dak John Morton filled in throughout the
original trilogy Jason windcream
provided his voice for the special
editions he was dubbed by Tamora
Morrison the actor who played Jango Fett
and when George Lucas needed more fat
footage for his special editions he
decided to just use three different
industrial Light and Magic employees who
happen to fit into the outfit finally
for the prequels younger Boba was played
by Daniel Logan who also provided the
voice for Boba Fett in the Clone Wars
cartoon and we're not even counting
video games radio dramas or Star Tours
King of the mandalorians though it's
been wiped out by Star Wars massive
continuity overhaul Boba Fett was once
the leader of his entire planet of
Mandalore just like his father was
before him what's the name of the leader
of all of Mandalore the fifth planet in
the Mandalore system quite simply
Mandalore that word probably works for
everything it's like Aloha Shalom Smurf
or squanch squanchy party bro oh
squatchy is there a good place for me to
squat around here you can Squatch
wherever you want man the actual history
of the Mandalorian seems to shift around
a lot but in the 2008 Star Wars novel
Legacy of the force Revelation that's
reluctant rise to power is spelled out
clearly he's hired to kill the existing
Mandalore leader Fen scheiser who ends
up saving fed's life but scheissa is
critically injured in the process as a
result Fett is bounds to honor his last
request that Fett himself become the new
Mandalore of Mandalore as such feds had
the mandalorians fight back against the
Alien yujang vong Invaders In The
novella Boba Fett's a practical man and
helped restore Mandalore after the war
make Mandalore great again right
vet's family another thing lost to
Disney's revised continuity was fed's
family which he started 16 years before
a new hope it's weird to think of fat as
a doting Dad but he and his Bounty
Hunter wife Sint as fell settled down
and had a daughter named aylin when vet
was only 19. unfortunately for everyone
sintas is assaulted by boba's boss who
Boba then kills sending him spiraling
into Exile and divorce since as ends up
frozen in carbonite for four decades and
their daughter goes on a misguided quest
to kill Boba Fett herself not only that
but aylin trains her own daughter
murdered her to follow in her footsteps
and you thought your family was messed
up all of that and Boba Fett still found
time to train the expanded universe
Daughter of Han and Leia Jaina Solo with
the help of feta and his granddaughter
murta gev jaina is able to kill her evil
brother Jason and restore peace to the
Galaxy so no matter what reality you're
following Han and Leia have one really
messed up evil kid the Skywalkers are
bad news the star Star Wars universe is
a rich tapestry but there are times when
it could have been even richer from
deleted subplots to abandoned action
sequences these are the Star Wars
deleted scenes that could have had a big
impact on the franchise
in A New Hope We Meet Luke Skywalker
when he and his uncle Owen purchased
C-3PO and R2D2 from a group of Jawas
it's a fine introduction and it allows
the narrative spine of the film to carry
through the two droids however deleted
scenes from the film revealed that we
were originally going to get to know
Luke in a different way George Lucas
shot several minutes of scenes on
Tatooine that were later cut from the
film which would have shown Luke doing
much more than farming in the scene Luke
sees the space battle that opens the
film through binoculars and goes to show
his friends what he'd seen these scenes
also introduced Luke's friend big Stark
lighter oh biggest ride I'm never gonna
get out of here
during their brief interaction Bix
explains his plans to sneak away and
join the Rebel Alliance while the scenes
would have slowed down the film a little
if they'd stayed in they would have also
added a large amount of World building
and helped explain some of Luke's
whinier Tendencies The Empire Strikes
Back features a famous moment in which
Leia plans a big kiss on Luke Skywalker
to make Han Solo jealous today
take it easy
it works but the moment is later
undercut by the Revelation that Luke and
Leia are brother and sister as it turns
out things could have been much more
Awkward a deleted portion of the kissing
scene takes place before Han enters the
room as Luke and Leia talk alone about
his recovery with his near-death
experience on his mind Luke begins to
tell Leia how he feels about her they
almost share a more intimate kiss but
they're interrupted by C-3PO because
that's just what 3PO was born to do the
sequence would have also featured Luke
revealing his plan to go to Dagobah to
Leia adding even more color to his inner
life
Greedo was first introduced in what has
become one of the most infamous scenes
in Star Wars history as a bounty hunter
confronting Han Solo but Greedo has a
history in The Phantom Menace one of
Anakin Skywalker's friends turns out to
be a younger version of Greedo in a
dewitted scene we see that the kid was
nasty from the start George Lucas shot a
lot of additional footage for Phantom
menace's pod race sequence including
more of the race itself and another
scene set right after the race the
deleted scene shows Anakin and Greedo
getting into a fight because Greedo
accused Anakin of cheating their fight
is broken up by Qui-Gon who tries to
explain to Anakin that he doesn't need
to argue if he knows the truth himself
the scene underlines the anger within
Anakin and also lets us know that Greedo
has always been a jerk for much of
attack of the Clones Anakin Skywalker
and Padme Amidala are on her home planet
of Naboo they're supposed to be there
for security reasons but all that time
alone together creates a romance deleted
scenes from the film revealed that the
Naboo trip included an extended sequence
in which Padme Disco says her political
career there's also an even longer scene
in which Anakin meets padme's parents
the sequence may have slowed the final
film down a bit but it adds a lot of
depth to Padme we learned that she
wasn't raised as royalty she loves quiet
family life and she's passionate about
helping around the Galaxy we also see
Anakin get grumpy when she tells her
parents that he's not her boyfriend
one of the best things about the
prequels is seeing the Jedi Order during
their greatest days that meant we got to
see lots of Jedi beyond the few we'd met
already sadly the films have to cover so
much ground that we don't get a chance
to get to know most of these other Jedi
they're mostly supporting characters who
barely get a word in a deleted scene
from the final battle and attack of the
Clones gave some of those supporting
Jedi more to do the missing scene is an
action sequence in which Jedi Masters
keandi Mundy and placoon Stage a raid on
a droid control ship the scene was never
finished but at least we got the Clone
Wars there is a lot going on in Revenge
of the Sith that means several deleted
scenes fell by the wayside and some of
them follow the rise of what would
become the Rebel Alliance these deleted
scenes paint a clear picture of a small
group of worried Senators discussing how
to make a move against Palpatine the
stronger Palpatine gets the closer they
get to Rebellion it's an intriguing
subplot and would have added quite a bit
more context for the future of the
Rebellion if it stayed in the final film
The Force awakens has to carry on a
story story that ended on the big screen
more than 30 years earlier and set up a
news story with a new cast of characters
that's a lot of ground to cover and that
means some aspects of the World building
are left to the imagination one of these
has to do with the resistance the
Republic and how General Leia Organa
factors into both Leia played a key role
in the formation of the new Republic but
when the first order Rose many people in
the Republic leadership wouldn't believe
her when she said it was a major threat
to their future so Leia founded the
resistance determined to stop the first
order before they destroyed the Republic
in a deleted scene from The Force
awakens this is given a touch more
detail as Leia sends resistance member
corcella to ask the Republic for help
sadly the scene was cut and we only see
corcella in one shot just before her
death as the first order destroys the
Republic The Last Jedi is the second
film in the sequel trilogy but the first
in that trilogy to really deal with Luke
Skywalker in a major way director Ryan
Johnson had to not just introduce this
new version of Luke but also explain the
complex emotions that led him to abandon
his friends and the force it's one of
the most important parts of the movie
but some things still had to be cut one
of the most powerful Last Jedi deleted
scenes come shortly after Luke figures
out Han is dead we don't get to see Rey
and Chewie tell him that his
brother-in-law and friend is dead but
one deleted scene shows us the aftermath
signlin and shaken Luke sits down in his
Hut and tries to deal with the loss of
Han you can see the despair on his face
along with the guilt as he wonders of
things might have been different if he'd
stayed It's a Wonderful performance for
Mark Hamill but it wound up on The
Cutting Room floor
Star Trek and Star Wars are often looked
upon as two sides of the same sci-fi
coin locked in a never-ending Battle of
philosophy versus action that will last
until the end of time or at least until
the arguing nerds need a nap in truth
both franchises probably owe their
continued existence to each other George
Lucas admitted that Star Trek basically
paved the way for Star Wars and William
Shatner conceded that Paramount only
became interested in giving Star Trek a
real shot on the big screen after Star
Wars took the World by storm in 1977.
generally fans pledged outright
allegiance to one franchise over the
other but that's an idea that the
following actors chose to ignore
entirely here are a few actors who
visited both the galaxy far far away and
the alpha quadrant George Takei Star
Trek Legend George Takei has been part
of the Enterprise from the very
beginning first appearing as Lieutenant
Sulu in the original series and going on
to reprise the role for Six Star Trek
feature films video games and even an
episode of Voyager but like many Star
Trek alumni it was through Voice work
that he made the transition between the
two biggest universes in sci-fi Takay
became the most high profile name to
take the leap when he landed the part of
General luck derd in the Clone Wars
animated series I congratulate you on
your good fortune when asked about
appearing in Star Wars take remarks that
he didn't consider it to be jumping ship
telling comic book resources the Star
Trek philosophies to embrace the
diversity of life and Star Wars is a
part of that diversity Star Trek is
science fiction and Star Wars is more
science fantasy but with the episodes of
Star Wars the Clone Wars that I worked
on I think there is emerging there Star
Trek and Star Wars living together in
harmony
Brent Spiner another Legend of track
Brent spiner's Runners Lieutenant
Commander Data spanned 15 years that
includes seven seasons of The Next
Generation and four feature films one of
which earned Award for best supporting
actor he also played data's brother
data's Creator and even made an
appearance in the prequel series
Enterprise as data's great great
grandfather so his place in Trek spans
more than just one series Spina
eventually put Trek behind him at one
point he even publicly took issue with
fans perception of the show saying in
2011 we carry guns it's a joke it's like
that illusion that it is somehow all
about peace it's really not
after provoking the wrath of trekkies
everywhere spina's subsequent casting in
Star Wars Rebels must have struck a
nerve the actor voiced The Senator gold
Travis a character who coincidentally is
a total traitor no kidding Brent no
foreign
Phillips though he pops up in everything
from girls to Veep to homeboys in outer
space Ethan Phillips most memorable role
Remains nelix the USS Voyager chef and
Ambassador Phillips portrayed the
talaxian for the show's entire seventh
season run but he also made three minor
appearances as different Star Trek
characters in next generation and
Enterprise Phillips played two different
Ferengi and he also made a cameo
appearance in Star Trek first Contact as
a holographic metro d Phillips has since
become something of a regular in the
world of Star Wars video games providing
the voice of Transport pilot Harmon flat
in Force Commander he also played an
imperial medical Droid kranti and
governor and the Royal grenade Trooper
in 2002's Galactic Battlegrounds as well
as several additional characters in
2003's Knights of the Old Republic hello
and hello to you you are new to the
academy aren't you
Simon Pegg British actor Simon Pegg is
known for many roles from his zombie
fighting hero in Shaun of the Dead to
his recurring role in The Mission
Impossible film franchise but track fans
know him as Montgomery Scott and JJ
Abrams Star Trek reboot movies he proved
to be such an asset to Abrams that the
director later admitted he had an
ulterior motive when he cast him in the
minor role of onkar blood in Star Wars
the Force awakens saying when we were
shooting the force awakens in Abu Dhabi
he was there as an actor but for me he
was there as a writer and filmmaker and
as someone to go around the issues I was
having at the time with the story and to
get some great feedback it probably
didn't take much for Abrams to convince
Peg to appear in the film either Star
Wars
I burned the Star Wars Peg's input
didn't end there either he was also
sought out by Paramount bosses when
Abrams left a Star Trek franchise
bringing Peg on board as a co-writer for
the third installment Star Trek Beyond
Ron Perlman best known for playing the
Demonic anti-hero Hellboy as well as his
starring role on Sons of Anarchy and a
few hundred voice roles Ron Perlman has
been around the block more than once
many of Pullman's hundreds of credits
lie in genre films an area of Cinema
he's always supported so when the
opportunity came along to join the cast
of 2002 Star Trek Nemesis as a rieman
vicerai Bowman asked his manager for the
time and place while he enjoyed working
on the movie neither audiences nor
critics seem to share his enthusiasm
fortunately his foreign to Star Wars
received a much more positive reaction
permanent voiced garnacht a transition
scavenger who meets his untimely end at
the hands of General Grievous in the
highly acclaimed first season of The
Clone Wars Ed Begley Jr veteran actor
and environmentalist Ed Begley Jr is
probably best known for its seven year
stint on Saint elsewhere though he
actually has hundreds of TV and movie
credits to his name among them are his
appearance on the Star Trek Voyager
two-parter Futures End in which he took
on the one-off role of 20th century
industrialist Henry Starling who just
happens to be working with a character
played by Sarah Silverman Begley Jr has
since said he felt really blessed to be
a part of the Star Trek franchise as a
huge fan of the show though that didn't
stop him from taking a gig with the
Rival franchise the very same year he
was hired to provide the voice of Boba
Fett in the radio adaptation of Return
of the Jedi produced with the blessing
of George Lucas and speaking of Boba
Fett Jason wingreen a victim of the
dreaded Star Wars DVD editions Jason
wingreen saw his part as the voice of
Boba Fett in The Empire Strikes Back
chopped and replaced with the voice of
tamura Morrison the man who played Jango
Fett in the prequel trilogy to add
insult to injury Wayne Green was never
actually credited for his contribution
to the Star Wars Universe which only
became common knowledge four years after
the great remastering of o4 while he may
be best remembered as Harry Snowden from
All in the Family for Star Trek fans
he'll always be Dr linke the Federation
scientist who gets sent to the
uninhabited Planet Manara 2 to conduct
studies in original series episode The
empath
Deep Roy the diminutive Deep Roy has an
impressive filmography stretching back
about 40 years including two big screen
Star Wars installments Roy played a
musician droopy MC cool in Return of the
Jedi a member of the max Rebo Band The
12-piece Ensemble that performs in Jabba
the Hutt's tattoo in Palace the four
foot three actor actually appeared and
credited in The Empire Strikes Back as a
body double for Yoda during a number of
scenes on Dagobah Roy is also one of the
very few actors to appear on screen in
both franchises playing Scotty's
oyster-faced alien sidekick Keen sir in
the rebooted Trek series kinsa was never
even meant to join Scotty on the
franchise's most famous Starship but
Roy's performance was so memorable that
they invited him back to reprise his
role Clancy Brown sci-fi fans shouldn't
really need an introduction to Clancy
Brown he's played The Immortal
antagonist the kurgan in Highlander
and Sergeant Zim and Starship Troopers
even your kids know Clancy Brown if only
in voice donate to the children's fun
what wouldn't children ever done for me
despite an impressive sci-fi resume it
wasn't until 2002 that brown showed up
on Star Trek taking on the role of
zebral in the Enterprise episode desert
Crossing in it Archer and Tucker accept
an invitation to his Homeworld and
unwittingly find themselves caught up in
a war among his countless voice roles
Brown also dipped into Star Wars
territory when he played Darth Maul's
brother Savage oppress in the Clone Wars
series as well as Ryder Azadi in Rebels
who only kind of looks exactly like him
Clive Revel renowned stage actor Clive
Revel portrayed a tweaked version of
classic English character sir guy of
Gisborne in 1991's Next Generation
episode Cupid which took the crew to the
12th century world of Robin Hood while
it wasn't the most memorable performance
the New Zealand native has given over
the course of his distinguished career
at least it wasn't replaced in later
edits like his work on the original Star
Wars Trilogy was
[Music]
thank you
sorry Rebel supplied the voice of
Emperor Palpatine in the first cut of
The Empire Strikes Back but like so many
others his work was dubbed over for the
2004 DVD release replaced with the voice
of Ian McDermott who took over as the
emperor with Return of the Jedi rebel
was humble about the change however
conceding that continuity was important
and saying that the filmmakers made a
good choice with McDermott considering
that the original 1980 Emperor was
played by a woman with superimposed
chimpais pretty much anything was an
improvement Craig grunberg as a
self-proclaimed geek Greg grunberg
couldn't have asked for a better friend
than a man who rebooted Star Trek and
kick-started the third Star Wars Trilogy
Greenberg has worked with JJ Abrams
almost exclusively so when Abrams began
his cinematic reinvention of Star Trek
he called on grumberg again drafting his
friend to overdub the dialogue for James
Kirk's stepdad
are you at your mind that car's an
antique you think you can get away with
this just because your mother's off
Planet you get your ass back home now he
appeared in person as Commander Finnegan
in 2016 Star Trek Beyond though by that
point he had already crossed the
franchise divide Bromberg played
resistance pilot Snapper wexley in
2015's the force awakens though he later
told star trek.com that he's on the
fence about which franchise is his
favorite Olivia d'abo
[Music]
best known to trekkies as Starfleet
Academy in turn Amanda Rogers from the
Next Generation episode True Q Olivia
Darbo is probably best known for playing
Kevin Arnold's hippie's sister Karen in
The Wonder Years Believe It or Not Dabo
considers herself to be a pretty big
sci-fi nerd telling the official star
Trekker website I considered it a real
honor to be working on the continuation
of the Star Trek Legacy I'd grown up
with it had a huge effect on my
childhood and nothing like Star Wars it
made me more curious about space other
life forms in our galaxy and The Wonder
of astronomy in general in 2008 she
joined a number of her former Star Trek
colleagues at lucasfilm to record the
voice of luminara and Julie for the
Clone Wars animated series and oh yeah
Patty Maloney emerging from The Darkest
Day in Star Wars history is Patty
Maloney who played a part in the
infamous and totally bizarre Star Wars
holiday special the 3 foot 11 actress
was hired to play the special's main
character Chewbacca's son lumpawaro
better known as lumpy no seriously
[Music]
Maloney's memories of the especially
weird program were completely positive
saying we were all very pleased with the
outcome of it actually I was I was very
pleased with it the special ed in 1978
and because of the sheer shame involved
was never seen again in any official
capacity Maloney's role in Star Trek was
another one created for a person of a
stature in the 1996 Voyager episode the
Thor she plays one of the many creations
of the clown a manifestation of fear
born of a linked neural network because
you know sci-fi this time she's credited
as only little woman which is still a
huge improvement over being a grunting
idiot named lumpy added bonus it was
even a speaking role oh boy and she got
to hang out with Michael McKean Point
Star Trek
[Laughter]
okay we're taking that point back when
it comes to the Sith the big bad
villains of the Star Wars Universe
there's more than one way to skin a Jedi
some Sith were strong in the force While
others wielded Sinister magic or a huge
political influence so who comes out on
top when you add it all up here are the
most powerful Sith ever freed and NAD
freed and NAD was a Jedi in the days of
the Old Republic with forced talents far
beyond any of his peers while training
he became jealous of his Jedi Master's
power and authority so in true Sith
fashion he killed him and renounced his
affiliation with the Jedi man what a
baby
[Music]
NAD was trained in the ways of the Dark
Side by Naga sadao a Sith Lord living in
Exile after his death freed and nad's
ghost continued to manipulate events
from Beyond the Grave
mark aragnos Marco ragnos was a Sith
Lord who grew tired of the Sid's
unwillingness to expand beyond their
Homeworld of korigan his Reign was
ruthless and brutal but most of the time
he achieved Victory without raising a
finger a master of manipulation ragnos
said his adversaries against one another
using their mutually assured destruction
to clear an easy path for the Sith and
his story didn't end with his death
either as a forced ghost He pitted Sith
Lords against each other for the honor
of becoming the official dark lord
[Music]
Darth Bane Darth Bane is the Star Wars
expanded universe's version of a
founding father when it comes to the
dark side of the force as the last
surviving member of the Sith Brotherhood
of Darkness Bane started a new Sith
order and decided to pass his knowledge
onto a single Apprentice establishing
the rule of two that the Sith Lords had
followed ever since
killed each other
victims of their own greed but From the
Ashes of Destruction
I was the last the last survivor I chose
the final John to only one
Darth Vader
as Anakin Skywalker the man who had
become Darth Vader was expected to
become the most powerful force user of
all time as he had the highest
midichlorian count ever recorded I heard
Yoda talking about midichlorians I've
been wondering what are midichlorians uh
let's not get into that but anyway after
massacring the students of the Jedi
Academy Anakin was severely wounded by
his master Obi-Wan Kenobi and as the
cyborg Vader he lost some of his
connection to the force still he had
perhaps the most impressive power of all
terrifying generations of moviegoers
[Music]
Darth nihilus the dark side of the force
can be seen as a metaphor for addiction
Darth nihilus offers a perfect example
after he was caught in the detonation of
the super weapon known as the mass
Shadow generator which destroyed the
planet malachor 5. nihilus's body was
wrecked he was left with an insatiable
craving for Force energy essentially
turning him into a force vampire yikes
revenant like so many other Sith Revan
also started as a Jedi he turned to the
dark side after the Jedi Council refused
to protect the lives of outer rim
innocence caught in the Mandalorian Wars
over their objections Revan assembled a
large Jedi defense team helping the
Republic win the war but leading him
down the dark path to corruption he
eventually embraced the light side again
and helped defeat the Sith I've known
both sides of the force light and dark
Darth Sidious better known to most fans
as Emperor Palpatine Darth Sidious Rose
to power thanks to ruthless cunning
after murdering his master dark Plagueis
the emperor hid in plain sight as the
benevolent Galactic senator from Naboo
secretly orchestrating the Clone Wars
which allowed him to consolidate
political power Darth Sidious corrupted
Anakin Skywalker and virtually wiped the
Jedi out of existence turning the table
after thousands of years of Jedi
dominance over the Sith I'm afraid to
deflect a shield will be quite
operational when your friends arrive
Darth vicious the original Emperor Darth
vicious tricked the other Sith Lords
into helping him perform a ritual that
allowed him to absorb the life force of
every other living being on his home
planet the ritual granted Vision
immortality and immense power which he
used to found a Galaxy spanning Sith
Empire ruling it with an iron fist for
1300 years
I have forged this Empire to surmount
all of my previous Works to spam
eternity here Palpatine had his moments
for a few decades but when it comes to
Sith Emperors there's really no contest
it can't be to do with 1300 years under
his belt I am awakened and I bring with
me
death
as anyone familiar with series Creator
George Lucas's original Star Wars
screenplay would tell you the process of
making the first film so special
involved throwing a lot of bad ideas
away so while most of the series worst
moments are confined to the three
prequels the movie that started it all
had plenty of cringe-worthy material
going into it which many of Lucas's
collaborators wisely fought to prune
appearing on The Tonight Show starring
Johnny Carson shortly after the Star
Wars Mania had begun to sweep the nation
in 1977 Mark Hamill shared his own
contribution to the Scripps Improvement
revealing one clunker of a line from the
original screenplay he talked Lucas out
of the doe eye log was a little bit
difficult I remember there was one line
that I just begged him to take out of
the screenplay he finally did boy I'll
never forget it as long as I live I
sometimes dream about this line the
passage in question came up during a
scene in which the crew of the
Millennium Falcon comes across what
remains of Princess Leia's home planet
Alderaan after it's been destroyed by
the Death Star the lion Hamill protested
came as a response from Luke to a remark
by Han Solo which Hamel quotes for
Carson with a charmingly Gruff Harrison
Ford impression
Harrison says look kid I've
heard the bargain when I get
my geroid you The Old Man and the droids
get dropped off that line in and of
itself wouldn't have been too out of the
ordinary for the swashbuckling space man
but what would have come next was pretty
ridiculous and my line was
but we can't turn back fear is their
greatest defense I doubt if the actual
security there is any greater than it
was on aqualiers and what there is is
most likely directed towards a large
scale us all even in a script filled
with confusing exchanges that one was
too much for Hamel
thought who talks like this George
the line would have still been far from
the worst bit of dialogue ever to be
uttered in the series but you can see
why Hamill wouldn't want to try and
deliver those words Hamill remembered
pleading for the line's removal out of a
sense of self-preservation this is
really not fair because you know we're
the ones that are going to get
vegetables thrown at us not you the
presence of the planet names aquilae and
solist in the convoluted line serves to
demonstrate just how much got chiseled
away from Star Wars script on its way
from page to screen in the original
story treatment aquale was a fleshed out
planet with the real world parallel of
communist North Vietnam by the time the
movie was shooting the names had been
reduced to a reference for the sake of
World building when Hamill prevailed in
removing the one line they appeared in
he deleted the planets entirely the line
that haunted Hamill isn't the only part
of Star Wars original script that needed
work and Hamill's not the only actor who
had issues Harrison Ford who plays the
space pirate in the film at one point
threatened to tie George up and and make
him say his own lines of gunpoint well
the cast complaints with the script may
have caused some friction their efforts
worked to sand down Star Wars rough
edges making it so most of the worst
stuff never made it out of the editing
Bay it all goes to show that when it
comes to collaboration compromise is
King otherwise you get The Phantom
Menace and how many great lines can you
quote from that
um
the Galaxy scruffiest looking Nerf
herder finally got a film all to himself
with solo a Star Wars story and as far
as all-out action-filled heist movies go
it's out of this world taking place
about a decade before Han would meet
Luke and his crew in a dingy little
Cantina on Tatooine solo gives us a
pretty clear backstory about the
troubled optimistic Han despite the
hero's General Detachment and
disenchantment from All Things Jedi it's
hard to escape common threads dangling
throughout the Star Wars Universe from
name-checked bounty hunters to familiar
face masks here are a few details you
may have missed in Solo
stay golden you'd be blind to not notice
Han's gold Dice and solo but they have a
very confusing history and even
canonical Star Wars Publications can't
seem to agree on what their deal is from
their first on-screen appearance during
a new hope the dice have taken on a life
of their own Star Wars the Force awakens
a visual dictionary includes a picture
of the dice they have standard Pips and
they were allegedly used in a game of
sebok in which Han won the Falcon from
Lando Calrissian when they make their
reappearance in The Last Jedi their
symbols have changed to alien characters
in Solo Han Hansa dice Takira before
they're separated on corellia the dicer
returned to him just before the crew of
the Falcon entered the spice mines of
Kessel but they definitely aren't used
during Han's subak Showdown with the
cheating Calrissian they're not even
used during Han and Lando's rematch in
which Han actually scores the iconic
ship so like so much of Star Wars lore
we're going to have to dig just a little
deeper and figure out the real story
behind those corellian chance cubes
questions about Kessel finally we get to
see what makes the Kessel Run so
dangerous and why it's a such a big deal
that Han Solo made it in less than 12
parsecs setting to rest the ongoing
debate about a parsec being a unit of
distance not time because of the fancy
flying necessary to make it through the
extremely dangerous area of space
finding a viable shortcut and surviving
it is a truly big deal most viewers
remember Castle because of Hans boasting
the average run takes 20 parsecs but the
Falcon made it in 12. that is if you
round down by the time A New Hope rolls
around Han's story grows and that number
dips to under 12. during the force
awakens Rey believes the number to be 14
parsecs which Han quickly corrects but
that's not even the first time Kessel is
mentioned in Star Wars the first mention
occurs in the first five minutes of a
new hope will be sent to the spice mines
of kessels in Solo we see that Kessel
totally sucks even though l337 staged a
pretty successful robot rebellion in the
mines Star Wars Rebels the visual guide
confirms that the mines have regular
rebellions all of which seem to be more
or less unsuccessful even a decade later
Kessel still sucks
big Bounty of all the lives lost in Solo
the definitive end to a fan favorite
Bounty Hunter was perhaps the most
surprising and it didn't even happen on
screen are saying who made a brief
appearance in The Phantom Menace went on
to appear in both canonical Star Wars
comics and multiple episodes of The
Clone Wars where she hung out with Boba
Fett and CAD Bane and even face down
Jedi Warriors Ahsoka Tano and Plo Koon
and then some time later she was pushed
by Tobias Beckett and met her
unceremonious end that's it for a once
respected Bounty Hunter what a way to go
also mentioned in passing is boss the
lizard-like Bounty Hunter who first
appears in The Empire Strikes Back
diving even deeper into Star Wars lore
the Zan sisters are also mentioned at
the same time as bosk while not an
obvious Riff on Star Wars Legends
continuity Zan and Zoo Pike were a pair
of mercenary sisters who first appeared
in Shadows of the Empire if there's any
doubt about their connection consider
teros Kasi the martial art mentioned by
Kira which is employed by her Vos and
Darth Maul among others it's first
mentioned in Shadows is used by the pike
sisters shows up in the title of a
terrible video game and is never
mentioned in Canon again until now
Legends even though Disney threw out
pretty much every Star Wars comic and
book that was written before they
acquired lucasfilm much of the new Canon
continuity of Star Wars is more or less
a remix of the old stuff at one point in
Han's original wiped out history he
joined the Empire didn't fit in and
eventually saved Chewbacca from the
Empire's abuse sound familiar
that's yes the maw also exists in old
Star Wars lore but it's a cluster of
black holes inside the Kessel Run the
idea is essentially the same in Solo
plus a horrifying space jellyfish for
good measure the parallels to things
viewers can find in the discarded
history of Star Wars are numerous but
you'll still never ever see Mara Jade on
the big screen sorry guys
Crimson Dawn Dryden Voss the leader of
the crime syndicate Crimson Dawn is
something of a collector Keen viewers
probably noticed a suit of Mandalorian
armor hanging around in the background
of his office which is of course similar
to the suits worn by the feds but it's
another curiosity in his office that
probably turned even more heads director
Ron Howard announced before the release
of solo that he'd planted an Indiana
Jones Easter egg in the film carrying on
a long tradition of the two franchises
trading references Treasures from the
Sankara stones to the fertility Idol are
hidden throughout the room but the most
obvious treasure is the gigantic Crystal
Skull that Vos has prominently displayed
vosis skull is definitely more humanoid
than the alien Cranium found in Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull but it's almost
definitely a reference to the Indiana
Jones film
aboard the Falcon for decades all we've
really known of the Millennium Falcon is
that it's a temperamental hearty little
freighter with a weird shape but you
might not have even recognized the ship
and solo during Han and Lando's first
trip we see that the ship is very clean
and also unusually teardrop shaped with
a whole lot of additions made by Lando
himself to make it more of a pleasure
vehicle than one for just serious
business these additions include a cape
room a hollow chess table and some nice
sleeping quarters interestingly the
shape of the old Falcon actually
reflects the original designs of artist
Ralph Macquarie despite all the damage
by the end of solo one thing we know for
sure remains aboard the Falcon is
Lando's Bounty Hunter helmet which we
first see in Return of the Jedi when
Lando enters Jabba's Palace using the
name temtel Screech Beckett uses the
same helmet to disguise himself on
Kessel
digging deep Lando clearly isn't a fan
of mining colonies but by the time the
Empire Strikes Back rolls around
Calrissian is managing Cloud City a
tabana gas mining Colony over bespin
keep your eyes peeled on the foul and
you'll spot a silver model of the colony
among Lando's possessions speaking of
clouds it may also come as a surprise
that enfus nest and her Cloud Riders
actually aren't a completely original
creation for solo they're actually
inspired by a band of marauders who
appeared in 1978 Star Wars number nine
but only in appearance the comic Cloud
writers are led by a guy with a terrible
name aragantis who definitely isn't into
piracy to help the Rebellion by then
Marvel Star Wars comics were already far
off the rails Jabba the Hutt was a
skinny yellow walrus on two legs while
Han was hanging out with a hedgehog man
named hedgie and a barely clothed Crime
Boss lady named amaza no thanks
weasel and Company
slow doesn't have as many secret cameos
as other recent Star Wars films but a
few are worth mentioning it would be
hard to miss the unusual presence of
Clint Howard brother of director Ron
Howard and a regular face for fans of
Science Fiction you'll spot him as a
robot Wrangler when we first meet l337
and while you won't find C-3PO solo
still features the droids actor Anthony
Daniels as a human named talk who teams
up with the wookies and Chewbacca during
the Escape from Kessel and of course we
have Warwick Davis who's been a part of
Star Wars since the very beginning most
notably appearing as Wicket the Ewok of
all his Star Wars characters only one is
unmasked weasel a scuzzy spectator at
the bunta eve Padres during The Phantom
Menace Davis appears again in Solo as a
member of the cloud Riders and once
again he's playing weasel going from a
racing junkie on a dirt planet to being
one of the Galaxy's founding Freedom
Fighters is an arc to parallel anyone
else in Star Wars and it's an arc we'd
love to see
on May 25th 1977 a pop culture
phenomenon was born after months of hype
a movie called Star Wars hit theaters
but what was it really like seeing the
film back in 1977 we've gathered
accounts from filmmakers journalists and
fans to take us back to a galaxy far far
away
[Music]
while it took a week or two for Star
Wars fever to fully catch on Nationwide
it was an overnight sensation in
California the film premiered at
Grauman's Chinese Theater in Hollywood
where it became completely normal to see
lines of fans camped outside the movie
house actress Carrie Fisher told Time
Magazine it wasn't like a movie opening
it was like an earthquake the Chinese
Theater was at the epicenter of that
earthquake and thousands of fans were
drawn to it every day speaking to CNN
Star Wars fan Chris baldeck were called
traveling from the San Fernando Valley
to Hollywood to see the movie on May
26th just one day after the film opened
the long line wound down the street from
Grauman's Chinese Theater and around the
block news helicopters hovered in the
air above the crowd Star Wars was the
first film to earn a reputation as a
party movie the fans brought costumes
beach balls folding chairs for the line
and an almost palatable anticipation
there was no better place to see it than
Grauman's Chinese in its pre-multiplex
days on advice from 20th tree Fox the
owners of the famous theater only booked
Star Wars for a two-week run when a
scheduling conflict meant they couldn't
show the hit film after that they
resorted to Desperate Measures and
refurbished in Old Cinema Larry Gleason
former president of Mann Theaters told
The Hollywood Reporter we moved Star
Wars there where it played for two weeks
before coming back to the Chinese
Star Wars toys would explode in
popularity over the next couple years
but back when the film was first
released the toys weren't ready and all
kids had was the movie itself George
Lucas's film became so popular with
youngsters that some of them were even
ditching school so they could see it a
lifelong fan Patrick Payne told
starwars.com unless you lived through it
and can remember it's kind of hard for
modern audiences to understand just how
different the world was in 1977 just
prior to the release of Star Wars I had
seen the trailers on TV and in the
theater months earlier they didn't say
much however what little they showed had
already triggered my imagination pain
sought out the novelization of Star Wars
which had hit the shelves in November
1976 after reading the book he knew that
he absolutely had to see the story play
out on the big screen Payne recalled
that a little thing like class wasn't
going to stand in his way I for one was
not going to miss this movie even and if
I had to miss school therefore I skipped
school sorry parents took the bus
downtown and saw the very first show on
opening day another young film
Enthusiast who saw the film on opening
day was Brad Bird who had later direct
such hit films as Ratatouille and The
Incredibles he described to CNN what
happened in the theater when Darth Vader
appeared on screen for the first time
and the audience simultaneously
booze and hisses like it's a silent
movie
in the mid to late 1970s there weren't a
lot of movies with broad
cross-generational appeal being released
which is another reason why Star Wars
did so well speaking to the official
Star Wars website on the 40th
anniversary of the film's release artist
Paul Bateman revealed that his father
wasn't really interested in seeing a
space movie at first but he ended up
having the time of his life Bateman
fondly recalled when we arrived at the
theater the line to buy tickets was
around the block and dad was bored
waiting in the line however not too long
after the opening scenes My dad became
just as engrossed in the film as I was
he was cheering and reacting along with
every adult and child in the audience
California Native Fred White had just
turned eight years old when Star Wars
came out and despite knowing absolutely
nothing about the film he was hugely
excited when his father told him they
were going to see it white reminisced
about that day to CNN he said it's
called Star Wars I clearly remember
thinking Star Wars that's a weird name
we saw it that day and I never thought
it sounded weird again like so many kids
his age Star Wars became a huge part of
White's childhood and he has shared a
special bond with his dad since that day
they even started a Star Wars tradition
and went to the opening day of the next
two films together
one of the reasons Star Wars managed to
stay in theaters for so long was because
people were returning for repeat
viewings there was even a healthy
competition breaking Out Among the
fledgling fandom when the topic came up
on Reddit one user recalled seeing Star
Wars over a dozen times the redditor
wrote it was absolutely the coolest
thing ever saw that sucker 14 times that
summer first movie I ever went to see
more than once what do you want to do
tonight
[Music]
again I'm leaving
you don't want to leave another Reddit
user recalled seeing it at least once a
week for the entire summer after getting
his initially reluctant friends hooked
on the film when it finally made it to
the discount theater we went as groups
every weekend through Year's End Of
course going to see a movie isn't free
it's all well and good when you're an
adult with a job to support your new
Star Wars Obsession but how did kids in
the 1970s manage to see the films so
many times Well 13 year old Russell
Burgess and his friend Scott maximized
their budget by getting three showings
for the price of one he admitted to CNN
we rode our bikes seven miles to the
biggest cinema in our area waited in
line three hours and then sat through
three viewings in a row hiding behind
the screen curtains and in the emergency
exit stairwells while the theater was
cleaned between shows
in a passionate medium article Star Wars
fan Rob Connery said that seeing the
movie in theaters at age nine was a
life-altering experience for him
reminding younger film fans just how
unique it was at the time according to
Connery it wasn't just the visual
effects that made Star Wars unlike
anything people had seen before it was
the whole package he wrote most movies
you would go see as a kid were kind of
crappy I remember really liking Escape
to Witch Mountain and Herbie movies but
As I Grew Older I wanted something more
more adventuring yes a little bit of
suspense and scariness too we just
didn't have that back then it was all
Goofy Disney Trek that all changed when
Star Wars came along according to
Connery it was the perfect Escape
activity for the pre-internet age when
kids didn't have endless entertainment
at their fingertips Connery added there
was absolutely nothing like Star Wars
when it came out I'm struggling to come
up with some relevant analogy for movies
today something that makes me jump up
and scream that alters your life
profoundly and makes you believe in
space travel exotic alien planets and
the force much like Connery fans from
around the globe had their eyes and
Minds opened to Endless Possibilities by
this film you've taken your first step
into a larger world
Petty Hammond creator of the everyday
fangirl blog won tickets to see Star
Wars from a local TV station the trouble
was the theater was a 40-mile round-trip
Journey from her family home Hammond
wrote about the experience for
starwars.com back then the freeway
system was not what it is today and a
trip to the theater took over an hour
however with dad being a big science
fiction fan we decided to do it Lucas's
Space Opera more than lived up to her
and her father's expectations Hammond
elaborated when we came out of the
theater he said mark my words this movie
will become a classic boy did he predict
that one of course back then it wasn't
uncommon to drive to a movie and see it
without ever having to leave your
vehicle Star Wars played as a double
feature with Smokey and the Bandit at a
number of drive-in theaters including
one in Kansas where cnet's Bonnie Burton
was watching in awe from the back of a
pickup truck Burton remembers with
Wonder the experience of seeing Star
Wars outdoors I can't adequately Express
the fun of watching Skywalker blow up
the Death Star on a big screen beneath A
Sky Full of twinkly stars as an
imaginative kid it was hard to see where
the Star Wars Galaxy ended and our own
night sky began after that experience
I'd stare up at the sky throughout my
childhood hoping to see the Millennium
Falcon Zip by Earth on its way to
Coruscant one of the reasons that Star
Wars got such an enthusiastic welcome in
1977 is because there wasn't a whole lot
of Joy at the time George Lucas's debut
feature
thx-1138 was a dark gritty sci-fi
experience but he grew up adoring
characters like Flash Gordon and wanted
to capture that type of magic with an
uplifting tale of Good vs Evil Lucas's
Vision apparently didn't go down well
among veteran sci-fi writers who didn't
want to see the genre watered down for
younger viewers August rigoni who saw
the movie on opening day told tested
they hated that Star Wars legitimized
sci-fi but at the time we needed Star
Wars we had a recession we had an energy
crisis and we needed some serious
escapism it was the perfect Adventure
movie for a kid and the kid and everyone
according to rigoni Star Wars lifted and
connected people the longtime sci-fi fan
also said it was a moment in time and a
shared experience that happened in
cities all across America it caught
everybody off guard and something like
that hasn't happened since even veteran
broadcast journalist Walter Cronkite
spoke highly of the film when he was
interviewed for the documentary Empire
of Dreams the story of the Star Wars
Trilogy Cronkite had this to say George
Lucas's Star Wars lifted us out of our
depression of the 70s and into an
awareness and focus on space and its
possible future this movie stood by
itself Lucas himself had a similar
perspective on the film and why it was
so successful it's been a long time
since people have been able to go to the
movies and see a sort of straight
forward wholesome fun adventure believe
it or not some people weren't that into
Star Wars when they saw it on the big
screen in 1977 while many veteran film
critics such as Roger Ebert waxed
lyrical about the film some of his peers
were definitely not impressed Joy Gould
boyum wrote In The Wall Street Journal
there's something depressing about
seeing all these impressive cinematic
gifts and all this extraordinary
technological skill lavished on such
pure oil materials
I find your lack of faith disturbing
it's hard to understand now but some
viewers were so underwhelmed that they
actually walked out of the film speaking
to starwars.com fantasy Steele revealed
that she watched the majority of the
movie alone at a theater in small town
Mississippi after friends decided to get
up and leave we arrived a little late as
usual just as R2 and 3PO were walking
across the Sands of Tatooine about 15
minutes later my friends declared the
movie to be lame and walked out I stayed
by myself and fell in love with Luke
Skywalker Han Solo and Princess Leia I
met with them again the following night
and again the following weekend although
it's tamed by today's standards for some
younger viewers Star Wars was actually a
little too violent in the UK one young
girl complained about the scene in which
Alec Guinness's Obi-Wan Kenobi protects
Luke and slices off Panda Baba's arm
with a swift stroke of his lightsaber
it's exciting but I didn't like the vet
when the man chopped off the person's
arm why not and they because it was plus
the Star Wars saga has become a
sprawling epic spanning numerous planets
alien races and massive Cosmic battles
in fact there's so much stuff happening
that sometimes it's hard to keep it all
straight and that's why we're here to
explain the entire Star Wars story The
Star Wars Story begins during a period
of relative peace in the Galaxy a
thousand years before the events of the
Skywalker Saga the Jedi Order defeated
the Sith order seemingly for good while
the Jedi became the keepers of Peace in
the galactic Republic the surviving Sith
secretly began plotting to overthrow
them it was near the end of this
Millennium a piece that darcidius a Sith
Lord who was secretly Senator shiv
Palpatine of Naboo set in motion is
planned to eradicate the Jedi and seize
control of the Republic's government as
part of his plan for Galactic domination
Sidious acted as a secret advisor to the
Trade Federation ordering them to
blockade and ultimately invade Naboo
once the Trade Federation arrived on the
planet city has slipped back into his
Senator Palpatine disguise and advised
naboo's Queen Padme Amidala that the
current chance of the Republic wasn't
acting in their best interests working
with this Sith Apprentice Darth Maul
Sidious was able to manipulate and
manufacture tensions in the Republic
from both sides meanwhile on a mission
to protect Amidala two Jedi Knights
Master Qui-Gon Jinn and his Apprentice
Obi-Wan Kenobi happened upon a young
Anakin Skywalker while repairing their
ship on Tatooine Qui-Gon discovered
potentially unprecedented levels of
force sensitivity in the boy after
taking Anakin with them Qui-Gon urged
the Jedi Council to train Anakin but the
Jedi were reluctant after qui-gon's
death at the hands of Darth Maul the
council accepted Anakin as Obi-Wan's new
Apprentice Palpatine was elected
Chancellor at Amidala's urging granting
him a place of unprecedented power to
further his plans following the events
of The Phantom Menace tensions within
the Republic continued to rise under
Palpatine's leadership Anakin Skywalker
grew into a young Jedi night of
considerable Force talents and finally
Darth Sidious took on a new Apprentice
former Jedi Count Dooku who adopted the
Sith named Darth taranus at Sidious
urging created tension in the Republic
by forming the separatists as numerous
star systems threatened succession now
Senator Padme Amidala fought to keep the
Republic together and was nearly
assassinated for her trouble Obi-Wan was
dispatched by the Jedi Council to find
out who was behind the attempt on her
life while Anakin stayed behind as her
bodyguard what about Senator Amidala she
will still need protecting
handle that your bad one will
Anakin Obi-Wan's investigation uncovered
an army of clones seemingly ordered for
the Republic by a dead Jedi Knight this
discovery LED Obi-Wan to discover a
separatist gathering on the planet
Geonosis back on the Republic capital of
Coruscant Chancellor Palpatine was
granted emergency powers to use the
newly discovered clones in the fight
against a separatist launching the clone
wars during this time Anakin and Padme
fell in love and Anakin's internal anger
grew as he discovered the death of his
mother on Tatooine the Clone Wars raged
for three years with Dooku as the
figurehead of the separatist movement
and Palpatine is the increasingly
powerful Chancellor of the Republic the
war raged across the Galaxy consuming
system after system as everyone picked
size the Jedi Order were tasked with
joining the conflict as generals of the
Clone armies discovered during Star Wars
Attack of the Clones as the conflict
raged Padme remained a force in the
Senate working for Unity while
mistakingly believing she could trust
Palpatine Obi-Wan and Anakin fought on
the front lines and Anakin even took on
a Jedi Apprentice named Ahsoka Tano
during this time he and Padme fell
deeper in love and they married in
secret however as the war went on
Anakin's darker Tendencies grew ready
for the final stage of his plan
Palpatine allowed himself to be taken
prisoner by separatist General Grievous
this kickstarted a rescue mission
leading Obi-Wan and Anakin to infiltrate
Grievous ship to rescue Palpatine once
inside they found Dooku and in the
battle with the Sith Anakin killed the
separatist leader at Palpatine's behest
with Palpatine rescued the Republic
pressed their advantage in the war and
Yoda and Obi-Wan were both sent to the
front lines in an effort to finish the
conflict once and for all back on
Coruscant Padme told Anakin that she was
pregnant and his dreams became troubled
by visions of his wife dying in
childbirth Anakin grew even closer to
Palpatine especially after the
chancellor hinted he might have
knowledge that could prevent Padme from
dying during childbirth or ever you ever
hear the tragedy of Darth Plagueis the
whites the push his plan into its final
stages Sidious revealed himself as a
Sith Lord to Anakin while also promising
him knowledge of the dark side Anakin
reported Sidious to Mace Windu who
attempted to arrest the Sith Lord during
the battle Anakin chose to save the Sith
all in the hopes that Sidious could save
padme's life with Mace Windu dead Anakin
pledged himself to the service of Darth
Sidious in the hopes he could prevent
padme's death Sidious dubbed his new
enforcer Darth Vader and then ordered
him to slaughter everybody inside the
Jedi Temple this began the great Jedi
Purge under Sidious Order 66 which
required all clone troopers to terminate
their Jedi generals on site only a
handful of Jedi like Obi-Wan and Yoda
were able to fend off their attackers
meanwhile in the Senate Palpatine used
his power to declare the Jedi Outlaws
and turn the Republic into the Galactic
Empire to end his self-orchestrated War
city has sent Vader to the planet
Mustafar to kill the remaining
separatist leaders and shut down the
Clone Army then Obi-Wan and Yoda made
their move Obi-Wan went to fight Vader
on Mustafar while Yoda confronted
Sidious on Coruscant on fortunately
Padme reached Vader first and when she
tried to convince him to see the error
of his ways he nearly choked her to
death by the end of Revenge of the Sith
Sidious fought Yoda to a stalemate while
Obi-Wan defeated Vader and left him to
die after facing the Sith Obi-Wan and
Yoda regrouped with Senator bail Organa
of Alderaan clinging to life after her
husband nearly killed her Padme gave
birth to twins named Luke and Leia
before passing away leaving the children
effectively orphaned Leia was adopted by
Organa and his wife while Luke was sent
to Tatooine to live with shmee
Skywalker's relatives the Lars family
Obi-Wan moved to Tatooine to keep watch
over Luke while Yoda moved to the swamps
of Dagobah to live in solitude in the
absence of the Jedi Emperor Palpatine
quickly Consolidated his vast power with
Vader by his side however even as he
celebrated his victory a small group of
leaders were already sowing the seeds of
rebellion one soon-to-be Rebel leader
was Han Solo a corellian orphan living
on the streets and working for a local
crime Lord when he failed to escape the
planet with his girlfriend Kira upon
enlisted in the Imperial Navy after
three years Han deserted and joined up
with an outlaw named Beckett to earn a
new life for himself as a pilot his
journey led him to reunite with Kira now
a trusted lieutenant in the Crimson Dawn
crime syndicate together they embarked
on a journey to steal a valuable
shipment of coaxium fuel for Crimson
Dawn boss Dryden boss along the way solo
met his best friend Chewbacca and
obtained this trademark ship the
Millennium Falcon at the end of the
adventure Kira chose to betray and leave
Han leaving Han to work as a Smuggler
for the next decade in the years after
the great Jedi purged the Empire tried
to exterminate any former Jedi still in
hiding meanwhile a small band of
resistance leaders grew more and more
organized and the Rebel Alliance began
to take root nearly two decades after
the fall of the Jedi there was a
breakthrough thanks to Galen erso a
rebel sympathizer who'd been forced to
work on the Death Star urso planted a
key flaw on the Death Star that would
allow the rebels to destroy it during an
all-out battle at scarif gen or so and
Captain Cassie and Andor give their
lives to steal the the Death Star plans
nearly 20 years passed between the end
of the clone wars in the Battle of
scarif and during that time Leia Organa
and Luke Skywalker had grown up on their
adoptive homeworlds Leia now princess of
Alderaan was a key member of the
alliance and managed to flee scarif with
the Death Star plans when she was
captured by Vader she hid the plans in
R2D2 who escaped a Tatooine in a pod
with his counterpart C-3PO on Tatooine
the plans fell into the hands of Luke a
farm boy with dreams of being a rebel
pilot after viewing a message from Leia
directed at Obi-Wan Kenobi he sought out
the old man and when the two met up
Obi-Wan revealed he was once a Jedi
Knight determined to get the plans to
Alderaan Luke and Obi-Wan booked passage
aboard Han Solo's Millennium Falcon
unfortunately Alderaan had been
obliterated courtesy of the Death Star
after our heroes found Alderaan
destroyed the Millennium Falcon was
pulled into the death star's tractor
beam giving Luke on and Chewbacca the
opportunity to search for Leia while
Obi-Wan disabled the station's tractor
beam a battle broke out as Luke Han Chui
and Leia shot their way out of the
station while Obi-Wan dueled Vader in a
long-awaited rematch sadly the Sith Lord
killed Obi-Wan in front of Luke back at
the rebel base on Yavin 4 the alliance
formed a plan to assault the Death Star
Luke volunteered to join the fight while
Han left with the reward money he'd
earned rescuing the princess at the last
moment Han returned to help in the
battle shooting Vader out of the sky and
leaving Luke 3 to destroy the Death Star
with the help of the force Luke saved
the rebel base and handed the Empire its
biggest defeat yet three years later
Vader finally located the alliance base
on Hoth and launched a full-scale
assault prompting a rebel evacuation Han
Leia Chui and C-3PO fled in the Falcon
while Luke left with R2D2 in his X-Wing
to seek Jedi training from Yoda on
Dagobah the Falcon made its way to the
gas planet to best spin where so met his
old friend Lando Calrissian who
unwillingly gave the Falcon and her crew
up to Vader Luke sensing his friends
were in danger went to best spin against
Yoda's wishes to save them after the
Bounty Hunter Boba Fett Pros Han Solo
and Carbonite to take him to Jabba the
Hut Vader and Luke fought in a
lightsaber duel during the fight Vader
caught off Luke's hand and revealed that
he was his father devastated and
heartbroken Luke left away from Vader
rather than join the Dark Side but
fortunately he was rescued by Leia Lando
and Chewie months passed as the team
developed a plot to rescue Han both Leia
and Lando infiltrated Jabba the Hutt's
palace while in Disguise but Leia was
captured after getting Han Solo out of
the Carbonite Luke sent C-3PO and R2D2
ahead as gifts for Jabba before entering
himself Jabba managed to capture Luke
and tried to have both Luke and Han
executed by throwing them into a sarlacc
pit luckily Luke had hidden his new
lightsaber in R2D2's body and with the
help of Han chewy and Lando Luke
destroyed Jabba's bodyguards meanwhile
Leia strangled the giant worm with their
own chains after rescuing Han Luke
returned to Dagobah to find Yoda dying
after Yoda's passing Obi-Wan's Force
ghost informed Luke that Leia was his
sister determined to complete his
training and restore the Jedi Luke
returned to his friends but in the midst
of the war the Empire had constructed a
second death star the second death star
was fitted with a shield around its
entire exterior generated by a satellite
dish located on the forest Moon of Endor
the rebel strike included a covert
attack to destroy the shield generator
along with a full-scale fleet assault to
destroy the Death Star itself once the
shield was down Luke Han Leia and Chewie
led the Endor team while Lando Admiral
Akbar and wedge Antilles led the fleet
strike meanwhile Luke turned himself
into Vader so he could face his father
alone on the Death Star as their battle
commenced Vader brought Luke before the
Emperor who attempted to convert the
young Jedi Luke resisted Palpatine's
control and fought against Vader however
after realizing he was becoming just
like his dad Luke refused to kill Vader
enraged by this the emperor torched loop
with Force lightning which led Vader to
pick up his master and throw him into
the station's reactor core on Endor Han
and Leia destroyed the shield generator
with the help of the Native Ewoks and
the rebel Fleet completed its Mission
destroying the Death Star and
effectively ending the Galactic Empire
as the new Galactic Republic began to
form with the help of major Rebel
Alliance figures like Leia and mon
mothma the remains of the Empire
retreated to the outer rim there they
fell under the command of a mysterious
Force user named snoke the ashes of the
Empire then gave birth to the first
order meanwhile Han and Leia had a son
Ben solo who showed the force prowess of
the Skywalker bloodline Luke made good
on his promise to rebuild the Jedi and
started a temple where Ben was a student
unfortunately snoke began to influence
Ben and the young Jedi turned on loot
converting some students and
slaughtering others heartbroken Luke
went into Exile sensing the threat of
snoke and the first order Leia formed an
underground movement separate from the
Republic a group known as the resistance
with his military commander General
Armitage snoke developed a massive
system-killing weapon known as
Starkiller base meanwhile Ben solo now
known as kylo Ren sought to find Luke
Skywalker Skywalker's location was
hidden on a piece of star map obtained
by resistance pilot Poe Dameron and
hidden in his Droid bb-8 the Droid was
ultimately found by a jakku scavenger
named Rey together with a first order
deserter named Finn Ray stole the long
dormant Millennium Falcon and left jakku
only to run into Han Solo and Chewbacca
while stopping off at the planet
takodana Rey discovered Luke's original
lightsaber before getting kidnapped by
kylo Ren with Han and Chewie's help Ben
was able to return Luke's map to Leia
and the resistance General Leia Organa
and the resistance launched a desperate
attack to destroy Starkiller base while
Finn Han Solo and Chewbacca tried to
rescue Rey while there Han confronted
his son Ben hoping to prove to snoke
that he truly turned to the dark side
kylo Ren murdered his father up on the
surface of the basis planets Rey took up
Luke's lightsaber and defeated kylo Ren
with their newly discovered Force powers
after the battle Ray journeyed with R2D2
and Chewbacca to a remote island on the
planet octo prepared to ask Luke for
guidance following Starkiller base's
destruction the first order sent a fleet
to the resistance base onto car Poe
Dameron led a massive attack on the
first order Fleet against Leia's wishes
losing most of the resistance's fleet in
the process while the resistance fled
Ray found Luke was unwilling to offer
her any assistance Rey was ultimately
able to convince Luke to help her but
Rey began sharing secret force-connected
conversations with kylo Ren ultimately
Luke and Rey had a falling out when she
tried to convince him that kylo was
capable of redemption rape led the
island while Force ghost Yoda burned
down the first Jedi Temple with ghost
lightning Leia and vice admiral holdo
staged the last ditch effort to save the
resistance from the approaching first
order HUD snoke's Flagship Rey allowed
herself to be captured so she could try
to convert kylo who initially seemed to
be on her side rather than watch Rey die
kylo betrayed his former master and
killed snoke but after fighting snoke's
guards together kylo asked Rey to join
him in ruling the Galaxy the Jedi the
rebels let it all die
Ray
I want you to join me Ray declined and
fled to the resistance on crate after
vice admiral holdo flew the resistance
Flagship into the first order Fleet
crippling their Starships new supreme
leader kylo Ren led a ground assault on
the last of the resistance on crate
their Loop face down the first order
assault and bought the resistance time
to escape on the Millennium Falcon
however the Lucan crates was a force
projection while the real Skywalker was
still back on octo the strain of
projecting his Consciousness across the
Galaxy was too much and while the
resistance lived to fight on Luke became
one with the force as Rey trained with
Leia to further develop her Jedi
abilities the resistance discovered that
Emperor Palpatine had returned Palpatine
made kylo Ren an offer kylo could rule
the galaxy as a new emperor with the
help of a long-hidden fleet of Planet
Killers if he agreed to kill Rey
meanwhile the resistance went in search
of a Sith wayfinder which could point
the way to Palpatine and stop his Fleet
before it launched as her anxiety built
during the mission Rey discovered a new
layer of darkness in her raising
societies over who she was built to a
peak when kylo Ren told her that he knew
her true Heritage she was the
granddaughter of Palpatine himself after
learning the truth Rey nearly killed
kylo in battle but healed him after Leia
intervened to save her son with her
dying breath Luke's Spirit urged Rey not
to give up and Ray journeyed to exigol
to confront Palpatine they are the
revived Emperor revealed his true plan
to convert her to become the new empress
and leader of the Sith Rey refused his
offer and fought Palpatine with the help
of a redeemed kylo Ren in the end both
the emperor and the fleet were defeated
and the Galaxy was saved in the
aftermath of the battle Rey forged her
own lightsaber and buried those of her
teachers in the Tatooine desert finally
she revealed that she had taken a new
name Ray Skywalker again it's like
poetry so if they rhyme every stanza
kind of rhymes with the last one
even without the iconic prologue crawl
or that classic a long time ago text
that precedes most entries in The Saga
most people could be dragged into a
theater showing a Star Wars film they've
never seen and still know exactly what
they were watching within moments here's
why
something really really bad always
happens pretty much every time a
bottomless shaft appears in a Star Wars
movie if the saga's heroes had any sense
at all they would have learned by now
that whenever they walk into a room with
bottomless shafts they need to turn
around and run the hell away Qui-Gon
meets his violent end at the foot of one
of these impossibly long tunnels in
Phantom Menace both halves of Darth Maul
plummet down one of those shafts just
like Darth Vader hurls the emperor down
one and Return of the Jedi Luke
miraculously survives a drop down Cloud
settings bottomless shaft and The Empire
Strikes Back and Obi-Wan hops over one
to turn off the death star's tractor
beam in A New Hope the heroes of Rogue
one also climb up one to get hold of the
Death Star plans and then there's some
Force awakens frankly Han should have
known better than to walk out over one
the shafts of Star Wars Are Legion and
if you see one you're probably in big
trouble
Star Wars movies tend to be bad for
Limbs and probably very kind to Black
Market Prosthetics dealers someone loses
a limb in most entries and whether
you're watching the movies based on
theatrical release or in chronological
order it's not going to take long before
someone loses something very important
to them Darth Maul loses everything
below his waist in Phantom Menace and is
revealed to have survived the ordeal in
the Star Wars the Clone Wars animated
series even making a cameo in Solo a
Star Wars story Anakin Skywalker says
goodbye to the first of many soon to be
lost limbs when Count Dooku relieves him
of an arm and attack of the Clones and
he loses the remaining arm in both legs
in Revenge of the Sith no major
characters lose limbs in A New Hope
though Obi-Wan does leave a canteen of
Bully's bloody arm on the bar and later
loses his entire body if you want to
count that Luke takes off a Wampus hairy
arm and Empire Strikes Back his father
sends Luke's hand spinning down a shaft
later in the film and Luke pays him back
by taking off one of Vader's already
replaced hands in Return of the Jedi
neither of the newest trilogies released
entries feature limb loss but both had
deleted scenes with amputations
Chewbacca tears off uncar plut's arm and
a snipped Force awaken scene and The
Last Jedi originally had Captain
phasma's hand sliced off by Finn just
before her death
first introduced an Empire Strikes Back
Yoda has proven to be one of the most
popular and off-quoted characters in the
Star Wars Mythos from his first scenes
in Empire the Jedi Master earned a
reputation as a near bottomless font of
wisdom great warrior
force not to make one great
although with the Advent of CGI and the
release of attack of the Clones the
syntax challenge Jedi was able to prove
himself a badass Warrior as well but
Yoda's also part of a Star Wars
tradition that doesn't begin or end on
Dagobah almost every entry in the
franchise includes at least one
character like Yoda someone who
initially seems physically unimpressive
but ultimately proves to not only be an
expert Warrior but a source of great
wisdom and usually information about the
mysterious Force even if the character
isn't a Jedi A New Hope gave us Obi-Wan
the oldest hero in the film's ragtag
group who nevertheless easily saves Luke
from Panda Baba and later fights Darth
Vader in a lightsaber duel Yoda fills
the role in both Empire and Return of
the Jedi as well as appearing in all of
the prequel films jirot imway is
arguably the most formidable
hand-to-hand combatant to appear in
Rogue one as well as being the most
vocal supporter of the force in the film
The enigmatic Maz Kanata plays part in
the newest Trilogy even though her
connection to the Jedi if there is any
hasn't yet been revealed people have a
lot of fun flying in Star Wars that's
not to say they shouldn't have fun
especially since they're usually just a
few minutes away from having their arms
chopped off and thrown down a bottomless
shaft why not make the most of it but
it's still kind of remarkable just how
much fun they're having and there's an
almost endless stream of Wahoos and
yeehaws to be heard throughout the
Saugus many stories and they usually
happen in the cockpit of a spaceship
whether it's Han celebrating finally
taking out a TIE fighter or even the
young Anakin Skywalker belting out the
occasional Wahoo while threading through
Trade Federation Droid Fighters Star
Wars heroes really like to yell even
when they're having a really bad day
take Finn who when he first escapes the
clutches of the first order with Beau is
wahooing up and down the Dark Void of
space as he and his new buddy both
narrowly escaped death
while the Star Wars Galaxy boasts a wide
variety of planets the planets
themselves don't tend to offer a wide
variety of climates and terrains in fact
the worlds of Star Wars tend to be
planets of extremes well our own Earth
has a few deserts for example if there's
a desert on a planet in a Star Wars film
then it's likely because the entire
planet is a desert like the reoccurring
setting of Tatooine or Force awakens
jakku if there's ice and snow on the
planet there's ice and snow everywhere
like The Frigid Planet Hoth in the
beginning of Empire Strikes Back there's
the swamp Planet Dagobah the ocean
planet kamino and the volcano Planet
Mustafar in Revenge of the Sith the
final location in Return of the Jedi is
even referred to as the forest Moon of
Endor in case visitors aren't quite sure
of what extreme and singular environment
they should expect
speaking of extreme planets how about
this no matter what the story is about
or who the lead character is the Star
Wars saga just keeps on bringing us back
to one of two desert planets usually
it's Tatooine though Tatooine is
replaced by the equally desolate and
arid jakku in the force awakens even the
rise of Skywalker is supposed to add the
Star Wars roster of desert planets with
the strange Rocky world of pasana now it
is a little surprising that Tatooine in
particular features quite so much in the
Star Wars Mythos if for no other reason
than a series set in a galaxy chock full
of planets inhabited by intelligent life
keeps swinging back to the same dry ball
of sand
well if there's a bright Center to the
universe you're on the planet that is
farthest from well the question of
tatooine's specific connection to the
force has yet to be directly addressed
in the films it would be surprising if
its reoccurring appearances had nothing
to do with a strong connection to the
force from Luke's training on Dagobah
and Empire Strikes Back and raise time
spent on acto in The Last Jedi we know
certain places in the universe are
particularly strong with the force
considering Tatooine is the birthplace
of Anakin Skywalker the childhood home
of Luke Skywalker and The decades-long
Hiding Place of Obi-Wan Kenobi it's
probably fair to say that the place has
at least some kind of significant
connection to the force as a whole the
universe is a big place and the Star
Wars Galaxy hides many Titans Star Wars
boasts enough giant monsters to fill the
cast of any decent Godzilla flick unlike
most of the monsters in Godzilla though
Star Wars Titans are weirdly good at
hiding especially considering their size
often these monsters even appear as
naturally occurring parts of the terrain
most famously there's a mighty sarlacc
of Return of the Jedi who swallows Boba
Fett and dozens of Jabba the Hutt's
henchmen from afar the sarlacc looks
like nothing more than a huge hole in
the ground but once you get close enough
to spot the teeth and the tendrils
you're probably already lunch equally
sneaky is the gargantuan space slug of
Empire Strikes Back who almost makes a
meal of the heroes when Han mistakes the
beasts insides for a cave then there's a
dianoga the Beast who almost drags Luke
to his death in the trash compactor
scene of A New Hope and who mostly
appears off-screen the rancor though not
exactly as cleverly hidden as the
sarlacc or the space slug is kept out of
sight for its first few scenes in Return
of the Jedi there are also the multiple
aquatic Giants who threaten the heroes
of phantom menace as they navigate
nubu's waterways and then of course
there's the massive tentacled Summa
verminos who tries to Devour the
Millennium Falcon in Solo droids don't
do what droids are supposed to do or
more commonly they do what they're
supposed to do but only after
complaining about it for a really long
time C-3PO is constantly arguing against
the hero's plans and R2D2 is usually
preoccupied with some secret mission in
Rogue one K2 second guesses all of
cassian's decisions and sets himself up
as the authority on who can and who
cannot be trusted while on solo L3 is
more concerned with starting a Droid
Revolution than with being helpful
ironically perhaps the best evidence of
this is in the rare example of a Droid
doing what it's supposed to do in
Phantom Menace R2D2 is introduced as one
of a number of droids who are dispatched
to repair Queen amidella's ship while
Under Fire
R2 is the only Droid to survive and
manages to fix the ship's hyperdrive
later Amidala thanks to Droid for its
service and orders it to be specially
cleaned as a reward which means
apparently a Droid doing precisely what
it was designed to do with such a rare
occurrence in the Star Wars narrative
that when it actually happens any nearby
humans feel the need to set up a
freaking award ceremony the Moss Eisley
Cantina from A New Hope is the setting
of one of the franchise's most
well-remembered scenes and also one of
its most replicated similar hives of
scum and villainy can be found in just
about every Star Wars film Jabba's
Palace in Return of the Jedi is
basically a larger grander version of
the Moss Eisley Cantina in one of attack
of the clone's few genuinely funny
moments Obi-Wan uses his Jedi mind trick
to convince a drug dealer in a bar on
corsant to rethink his path in life
fittingly solo features almost nothing
but these places of ill repute starting
with the Crime Boss Lair Han escapes on
corellia the casino on bandor where Han
first meets Lando and later the bar on
numidian Prime where Han finally wins
the millennium and Falcon from Lando
shortly after Han meets Finn and Ray in
the force awakens he brings him to Maz
kanata's cantina-esque Castle on
takodana and while its leader and
soldiers were extremist Rebels rather
than bounty hunters and criminals saw
guerrera's stronghold on Jeddah felt a
lot like Jabba's Palace then there are
the examples that seem more upscale but
are nevertheless just as villainous like
Dryden boss yacht in Solo and the casino
that caters to the super rich residents
of Kanto bite in the Last Jedi they're
fancy sure but that doesn't make them
any nicer a Star Wars movie with no
lightsaber fighting is surely no Star
Wars movie at all
elegant weapon
for the more civilized day
in the earliest films The Duel usually
takes place toward the end Obi-Wan
battles Vader in A New Hope Luke's
Empire Strikes Back fight with Vader is
perhaps the most iconic of all the duels
and once he's fully trained Luke proves
his skills Superior to Vaders in Return
of the Jedi the prequels brought us the
manically choreographed battle between
Darth Maul Qui-Gon and Obi-Wan and
Phantom Menace Obi-Wan and Anakin are
both humbled by Count Dooku in Attack of
the Clones though they're saved when
Yoda bursts out his crazy lightsaber
skills for the first time on screen
Revenge of the Sith was the first film
to deliver a duel right at the beginning
a rematch between Anakin and Dooku along
with the Jedi council's doomed attempt
to capture Palpatine General Grievous
forearmed assault on Obi-Wan Yoda's
fight with Palpatine and Kenobi's
victory over Anakin on Mustafar the
force awakens was the first time the
series portrayed a woman on either side
of a lightsaber duel as Rey takes on
kylo Ren after the latter easily defeats
Finn weirdly there's little saber on
saber action in The Last Jedi Kyle when
Ray fight back to back against snoke's
Elite praetorian guard Finn uses an
energy baton rather than a lightsaber
when he attacks phasma and the Luke who
faces kylo at the end of the film turns
out to not have been there in the first
place the only instance in which one
lightsaber physically clashes with
another actually takes place during a
flashback
Star Wars climaxes tend to follow one
particular multi-layered formula in the
sense that there's usually one main
conflict made up of two or three smaller
battles usually there's at least one
large-scale military Clash contrasted
against a much more personal one-on-one
fight Return of the Jedi establishes the
formula on Endor the Ewoks and the rebel
Ground Forces fight the Imperial troops
to take out the death star's Shield
generators and in Space the rebel Fleet
clashes with the Imperial type Fighters
and Star Destroyers meanwhile on the
Death Star Luke and Vader crossed
lightsabers one last time the formula
returns in Phantom Menace the gungan
Army faces off against the Droids on
Naboo Obi-Wan and Qui-Gon have their
fateful duel with Darth Maul in the
palace while Naboo Fighters battle the
trade federation's Droid ships in space
likewise the end of the force awakens is
split between the rebel fleet's attempt
to take out Starkiller base and the
lightsaber duel in the snow Rogue one's
tragic final Clash depicts yet another
space battle a large-scale ground
assault and the efforts of Jin Cassian
and k2s so Define and transmit to death
star plans Revenge of the Sith is one of
the few entries to not include a huge
military battle instead going back and
forth between the Obi-Wan and Vader duel
on Mustafar and the fight between Yoda
and Palpatine on coruscantes a new hopes
all-out assault on the Death Star
actually seems pretty simple in
comparison
it turns out all our teachers were wrong
the correct way to count is four five
six one two three seven eight nine well
at least from a certain point of view
Star Wars is known today as a cultural
phenomenon but it wasn't always seen
that way the original film A New Hope
was released back in 1977 with little
hope of success by even its creator
George Lucas according to screen prism
Lucas was so sure of its failure that
when it was released in cinemas he was
hiding out in Hawaii on vacation but
Lucas must have had some belief the
movie could be a hit because buried deep
in his mind was a plan to turn what
looked like a standalone film into a
series of movies and then something
incredible happened
strike me down I shall become more
powerful than you can possibly imagine A
New Hope then simply titled Star Wars
defied the odds and became a mega hit of
Galactic proportions A New Hope was
followed by The Empire Strikes Back In
1980 and return to the Jedi came after
in 1983 to complete the original Star
Wars Trilogy then in 1999 a fourth Star
Wars film was released only it wasn't a
fourth film it was to be the first one
on the Star Wars timeline The Phantom
Menace is in fact episode 1. it was
exceeded by episode 2 attack of the
Clones in 2002 and episode 3 Revenge of
the Sith in 2005 to comprise a Star Wars
prequel trilogy more films were released
from 2015 to 2019 the force awakens The
Last Jedi and the rise of Skywalker
which were sequels to the original Three
Star Wars films but why create them in
this order why not make the first Star
Wars Trilogy prequels then create two
separate sequel collections the answer
is a lot simpler than its accompanying
questions suggest author Michael
Kaminski writes in the secret history of
Star Wars that Lucas decided to start
with the fourth episode quote due to
Technical and storytelling reasons he
further explained Lucas had a massive
expensive Epic on his hands and divided
the story into three separate films he
had also developed a backstory for his
elaborate tale which together totaled
six chapters and sought to make episode
4 first due to Technical and
storytelling reasons when the film by
some miracle went into production it was
beset by problems of all kinds and Lucas
was sure it would be a failure and was
shot when it became the biggest
sensation of the Year Lucas himself has
corroborated this claim he admitted the
Star Wars series started out as a movie
that ended up being so big that I took
each Act and cut it into its own movie
when I first did Star Wars I did it as a
big piece it was like a big script it
was way too big to make into a movie so
I took the first third of it which is
basically the First Act and I turned
that into what was the original Star
Wars the story of the New Hope gave no
context of the world in the film
throwing viewers straight into the
action without any background knowledge
doing so would later give Lucas the
opportunity to go back and provide some
context in the prequels from the release
of the first Star Wars film there was
talk that Lucas had three trilogies in
mind one of which would be a prequel
trilogy that would deal with the
political background needed for the
Empire to become what it was in the
original movie Lucas always knew he
wanted to create an entire galaxy far
far away not just a standalone film
there's plenty of evidence of that and A
New Hope with references to the Clone
Wars the Jedi Order and the Castle Run
hinting at an untold story it took a
number of different drafts of the first
Star Wars film before the story of Luke
Skywalker A Poor Farm Boy from Tatooine
who discovers he has Jedi powers and
joins a band of rebels against an evil
dictatorship in the form of the Empire
took shape leaving other characters by
the wayside to have their stories told
later Lucas kept them in the bank and
put some of his ideas into the film and
passing mentioned to give that backstory
mace Wendy who became Mace Windu in the
final story an Anakin Starkiller later
Anakin Skywalker are among the
characters who were initially meant to
be in the first film in Lucas's early
drafts both appear in the Star Wars
prequels although Anakin was technically
part of the original trilogy given that
he eventually transforms into Darth
Vader Lucas had a pretty specific vision
in mind for a new hope he wanted the
film to fade in with audiences making it
feel like they were coming in halfway
through a larger story it would pave the
way for Lucas to be able to turn the
film into a full movie series and he
already had the groundwork laid for the
backstory he would need to tell but what
about the final Trilogy of the Skywalker
Saga headlined by the powerful young Rey
you might be wondering though Lucas
already had it set in his mind to make
episodes 7 through 9 way back when he
hadn't yet mapped the actual story that
would unfold in those three films what
he did know was that he wanted the
original Three Heroes to make a return
according to comicbook.com
the Star Wars series includes some of
the biggest bookbusters of all time
during no small part to the rabbit and
meticulous fandom thus followed It
Through The Years even after a thousand
viewings there are still some things you
may have missed in that galaxy far far
away here are a few hidden details in
Star Wars movies
Lucas family cameos George Lucas
resisted the temptation to go Hitchcock
during the original Star Wars movies and
make Cameo appearances but he did allow
himself a few indulgences during the
prequels his son and daughter appear in
the prequel trilogy that's jet Lucas you
see in the library and attack of the
Clones and again kicking Clone Trooper
Birds when the Jedi younglings are
attacked during Revenge of the Sith
Lucas himself appears alongside his
daughter Katie in the latter film
playing the blue-skinned Baron not the
whiskey Papa Noida who became a regular
in the animated Clone Wars series and
speaking of cameos Boba Fett unmasked
officially Star Wars fans didn't get
their first look at a helmetless Boba
Fett until the second prequel attack of
the Clones but the guy who played Fett
in the original films Jeremy Bullock
actually showed his face in The Empire
Strikes Back when another actor failed
to show up for filming during the shoot
Bullock stepped in to play an imperial
officer who drags later away while she's
trying to warn Luke about Vader's trap
in bespin years later Bullock returned
for another non-fat Cameo playing the
pilot who delivers Obi-Wan Kenobi and
Yoda to Coruscant in Revenge of the Sith
the fat Legacy doesn't end there however
clutches Stormtrooper DNA hardcore Star
Wars fans know about the Stormtrooper
head bump goof up that made it into the
Final Cut of A New Hope rather than
correct the mistake George Lucas paid
tribute to it when he had the character
of Jango Fett whose DNA was used to
create the first clone Trooper Army
whack his head on the door as he climbed
into his ship clone troopers were
eventually phased out for conscripted
Stormtroopers but some clone troopers
remained in service guess you know who
this guy's dad was cell block 1138 yeah
before embarking on the Star Wars saga
George Lucas made his big screen
directorial debut with the 1970 sci-fi
feature
thx-1138 it wasn't a major commercial
success so many viewers initially missed
a significance when Luke Skywalker makes
a reference to the Death Star cell block
1138 drawing a new hope
where are you taking this
thing
prisoner transfer from cell block 1138
corellian Freighters it's easy to
believe that the Millennium Falcon is a
one-of-a-kind spaceship after all while
we saw plenty of x-wings and Tie
fighters zipping through space we never
got a look at anything like another
Falcon but the truth is that Han Solo's
beloved freighter was just one of many
in the corellian yt-1000 line George
Lucas lived in several of them in the
background during the prequels including
a brief shot of the Falcon herself
spotted ducking a Coruscant long before
solo claimed ownership that's not the
only hidden detail featuring the fastest
hunk of junk in the galaxy
Millennium Falcon's new dish we don't
know much about what happened to the
Millennium Falcon after it lost its
radar Edition Return of the Jedi it was
too close but it's obvious that someone
did a little repair work along the way
the ship was giving a rectangular
replacement that you can clearly see
during the force awakens maybe it wasn't
still by the same person who worked on
C3PO
probably don't recognize me because of
the red arm
Vader's helmet when Palpatine invites
Anakin into his private booth during a
performance of the bubble opera during
Revenge of the Sith the audience already
knows the young Jedi will be corrupted
into becoming Darth Vader but to add
that extra little bit of nearly
subliminal foreshadowing George Lucas
inserted an almost imperceptible glimpse
of Vader's helmet into the show some
viewers swear they can hear what sounds
like a couple seconds of Vader breathing
way down in the mix
potato Asteroids for years rumors have
persisted that The Empire Strikes Back
effects crew annoyed by George Lucas's
almost impossible demands decided to
strike back by using a potato and a
sneaker as asteroids during a Millennium
Falcon Chase sequence years later it was
revealed that the potato story was
actually true an in-joke between workers
who developed countless asteroid designs
only to be told that the end result
looked like a certain starchy food
potatoes
Skywalker sound there's a lot going on
in Coruscant making it easy for Lucas to
sneak in the logo for a Skywalker sound
company drawing a brief shot of the city
in Attack of the Clones take a look at
the blue circular logo at the top right
section of the screen busted Ralph
mcquarie's Cameo do
dreamed up the Star Wars Galaxy but the
iconic designs that amazed generations
of moviegoers came from designer Ralph
McQueary his concept art introduced a
number of key elements to the series and
were instrumental in Lucas Landing a
distribution deal with 20th Century Fox
macquarie's presence has felt throughout
the Saga but he actually appears in
person during a scene in Empire Strikes
Back he can be briefly spotted as a
rebel officer walking through the base
of half
R2 KT keeping version of R2D2 R2 KT was
originally a fan Community project
designed to help lift the spirits of
Katie Johnson a young Star Wars
Enthusiast had been diagnosed with an
inoperable brain tumor dreamed up by her
dad as a way of giving Katie a bit of
comfort during her final days the Droid
received her official live-action
feature film debut during the force
awakens making brief appearances during
scenes set on the resistance base I
guess let's hope for Humanity after all
what were the prisoners making on
arquina 5 the season finale of Andor has
a post-credit stinger he may have missed
which answers that very question keep
watching to find out all the details
Disney's Andor occupies a special place
in the Star Wars timeline the prequel
movies ending with Revenge of the Sith
see the bureaucratic Galactic Republic
corrupted and taken over from within by
an individual using emergency rules and
parliamentary edicts designed to
consolidate power of course by the time
Star Wars A New Hope comes around the
Republic has been replaced by the Empire
which uses fear tactics and overwhelming
Firepower to suppress descent the most
infamous example of this is the Death
Star a massive space structure capable
of destroying planets and being
occasionally mistaken from moons Andor
is nestled in the time before the
original Star Wars Trilogy and after the
prequels and or itself is a prequel to
Rogue one a Star Wars story which sees
Cassian Andor and jyn urso make a
faithful sacrifice in order to deliver
the plans for the Death Star to the
Rebel Alliance and the movie pretty much
ends exactly where A New Hope picks up
with Darth Vader pursuing the ship of
Princess Leia now that Andor has
completed its first season the ending
Stinger helps bring a greater Focus to
this era of Star Wars history and it
certainly gives Cassian a very specific
reason to hate the Empire and its super
weapons Andor starts with small enough
Stakes as Cassian looks for any clues to
the location of his lost sister on the
planet to Moreland one unfortunately he
is shaken down by two security officers
which results in Cassian killing both
this starts off a localized hunt for
Cassian though soon the Empire gets
involved when it's revealed that Cassian
had access to an imperial starpath unit
an exceptionally hard to get item that
would allow one to track Imperial
vessels although Cassian wants nothing
to do with Rebels he accepts a job on
aldani which involves stealing the
Imperial payroll for an entire sector
completing his task Cassian receives his
massive payday and decides to lay low
unfortunately Imperial forces are
engaged in a galaxy-wide Crackdown and
he is charged as a vandal even though he
is innocent given a six-year prison
sentence Cassian is sent to markina 5 an
imperial prison and industrial complex
forced to work on some unknown project
Cassian and his fellow inmates are kept
in line by an electrified floor
eventually becomes known that none of
the prisoners are getting a chance to
leave even and after their sentences are
up which causes Cassian to organize the
successful escape two episodes later and
after a bombastic finale It's Finally
Revealed what Cassian and his fellow
inmates were working on the original
Death Star this Stinger post credit
scene at the end of the first season of
Andorra establishes just how The Empire
is able to create to fearsome Planet
destroying Weapon by utilizing prisoners
that may or may not be innocent the
Empire is able to create a Workforce
that cannot complain quit leave or even
tell others what they are working on
which would endanger the Empire's
doctrine of ruling through secrets and
fear as noted by the Sun the original
Death Star measures around 75 miles wide
which for the math incline results in a
volume of 32 quadrillion 515 trillion 31
billion 575 million three hundred and
twelve thousand two hundred and three
cubic feet these numbers certainly
illustrate just how much effort had to
go into the clandestine project and how
long the Empire had been working on the
Planet Killer it's also important to
remember that the original design for
the Death Star came from the geonosians
during the events of attack of the
Clones another aspect to consider
involving the construction of the Death
Star is that by the Empire utilizing
prison labor they are able to harness a
tremendous amount of Labor that the
Empire doesn't need to worry about
talking this is probably another reason
why none of the other prisoners on
archina 5 are allowed to leave the
Empire doesn't want to risk anybody
putting together what their project is
this makes sense considering that planet
killing weapons are probably a tough
sell to all but the most stringent of
Imperial supporters and citizens this
reveal although currently unowned
Cassian certainly helps establish some
of his motivation in Rogue one Cassian
throughout season 1 of Andor certainly
isn't committed to the Rebel Alliance
cause he simply wants to get paid settle
his debts find his sister and be left in
peace and he doesn't love the empire in
any sense he certainly isn't trying to
take down the oppressive regime of
course by the Time season 2 rolls around
Cassian will be much more dedicated to
the cause especially considering what
his adoptive mother Marva said in a
recorded message after her death the
teaser scene featuring droids putting
the Death Star together at the end of
Andor and the fact that Cassian had been
working on the Death Star the entire
time was something that the series had
always been building towards speaking
with polygon showrunner Tony Gilroy said
we came up with the prison and the
building of the park pretty early on it
was like oh they should be building the
Death Star and then you know you follow
it forward and it's like oh you know
what we ought to show that so the visual
effects department just loved that idea
and they ran with it still it will be
interesting to see where season 2 of
Andor leads and how much Cassian will
change over the upcoming course of
events before the events of Rogue one
with seven main Saga installments an
anthology movie and numerous television
releases and animated spin-offs Star
Wars is undoubtedly one of the biggest
Hollywood properties ever however just
being a Star Wars movie isn't enough to
guarantee success and there have
definitely been some missteps along the
way we're looking at you Lumpy
here's a look back at all the movies
that are part of the massive phenomenon
that is Star Wars as we rank them in
order from worst to best Star Wars the
Clone Wars while 2008 Star Wars the
Clone Wars made history as the first
fully animated Star Wars feature-length
film it isn't great essentially a TV
pilot package for the big screens it was
almost universally panned by critics and
audiences with a script filled with
stilted dialogue and force tension the
Clone Wars just wasn't suited for the
big screen nevertheless it succeeded at
the box office and worked as a vehicle
to introduce audiences to Cartoon
Networks the Clone Wars animated series
which went on to be extremely popular
Star Wars holiday special until the
Clone Wars came along
1978's Infamous Star Wars holiday
special reigned as the absolute worst
Star Wars movie the show starts with 10
minutes of untranslated Wookie dialogue
with no Han Solo around to translate it
and then things go bizarrely downhill
from there segments include a b Arthur
musical number humorless comedy bits
cameos by Hollywood stars and an
appearance by the rock band Jefferson
Starship because well their name has the
word Starship in it the one bright spot
of the holiday special is a cartoon
introducing the character of Boba Fett
but the rest is like watching a
slow-motion train wreck for his part
George Lucas later claimed if I had the
time and a sledgehammer I would track
down every copy of that show and smash
it at least we know what he'll be doing
during his retirement the Ewok Adventure
while the Star Wars holiday special has
a mostly nonsensical plot the simplistic
sci-fi fairy tale in 1984 is the Ewok
Adventure at least has a beginning
middle and end this key difference as
well as the massively better production
values push it past the much maligned
1978 special still after it aired on
November 25th 1984 the reviews were
lukewarm at best which isn't surprising
given the young target audience but they
weren't done with Ewoks just yet Ewoks
the battle for Endor the Ewok Adventure
was the first of two spin-off films set
on Endor the 1985 sequel Ewoks the
battle for Endor continues the tale
begun in the first TV movie but with a
slightly meteor and more serious plot
like its predecessor the battle for
indoor one enemy had a brief overseas
theatrical run and made it onto home
media in various forms the battle for
Endor is marginally better than the Ewok
Adventure but even with its stronger
plot this sequel isn't deep enough to
make elastic impression even with an
ornery Wilford Brimley episode 1 The
Phantom Menace in 1999 the hype
surrounding the new Star Wars prequel
trilogy was off the charts unfortunately
episode 1 The Phantom Menace was a
complete letdown even for many of the
young fans it was geared towards did
George Lucas really think that kids
would want to watch a movie about
embargoes Taxation and political
Intrigue while visually impressive The
Phantom Menace gets lost in its own
narrative and that's even before Jar Jar
Binks shows up
don't do that again there are a few
saving Graces in The Phantom Menace
namely Ian McDermott's performance as
Palpatine just about everything with
Darth Maul and the battle on Naboo are
bright spots in an otherwise pretty dull
movie it's not the bottom of the barrel
but The Phantom Menace is clearly the
worst of the main Skywalker Saga films
so far episode 2 attack of the Clones
following The Phantom Menace fans cross
their fingers that Lucas could manage to
pull things together for the next
installment if there's one thing we can
say for Attack of the Clones it's that
it's better than the phantom menace it
has some of the more entertaining action
sequences seen thus far in the entire
Saga the fight between Obi-Wan and Jango
Fett on Camino and the later battle seen
on Geonosis are wonderful examples of
action done right but even with all
those positives what really hurts this
movie more than anything is the awful
dialogue you could even call it
unbelievably bad but only if you haven't
seen the fans of Menace also this scene
of Anakin riding a cow-shaped watermelon
didn't help one bit episode 3 Revenge of
the Sith a modern re-watch of Revenge of
the Sith allows its good points to shine
through without being clouded by the
hate that was associated with the
prequels back during its initial release
to start with the film is much darker
than most of the other Star Wars films
being first in the Saga to Garner a
well-deserved PG-13 rating many of those
dark moments like Order 66 and the Jedi
Purge are surprisingly brutal
additionally the lightsaber battles and
Revenge of the Sith are more exciting
and better choreographed than any that
came before paired with John Williams
amazing score the battles between
Obi-Wan and Anakin and between Yoda and
sidious are some of the most impressive
in the entire franchise as the third
film in a Trilogy Sith also ties up
Anakin's Ark with his transformation to
Vader yes It suffers from the same rough
dialogue and overacting as the rest of
the prequels but Revenge of the Sith
stands solidly is the best of that
series episode 6 Return of the Jedi yes
return of the Jedi is a classic and fans
who grew up with the original films
don't like to admit many of its faults
but that doesn't mean those faults don't
exist the most glaring of those has to
be the indoor section at least where the
Ewoks are involved and while Han's
rescue at the beginning of the film is
very enjoyable especially the comic
relief provided by Hans blindness the
Tatooine scene tends to drag on a little
too long although many fans felt a
little cheated by the rehashing of the
Death Star plot the space battle around
the Death Star turned out to be one of
the best in the history of the franchise
and you can't argue too hard against the
story's closure especially watching
Vader come full circle and regain his
Humanity at the end of the day Return of
the Jedi is a solid enjoyable and flawed
part of the Star Wars saga no matter
which version you're watching Rogue one
a Star Wars story Rogue one stands
mostly on its own merits it doesn't rely
on too many familiar characters and
allows Disney and lucasfilm to explore
new stories in the Galaxy that don't
revolve around the Skywalker family and
their Pals at its heart Rogue one is a
war movie not a typical Star Wars Space
Opera it's filled with great action
sequences and a cast of supporting
characters that you actually start to
care about additionally it gives us yet
another believable and strong female
hero in Gin erso on the negative side
some of the dialogue is clunky and the
CGI used to create Grand Moff Tarkin and
Princess Leia Ventures into uncanny
valley more than once that said these
are mostly minor issues with what is
overall a very solid Star Wars film
episode 7 the force awakens when
lucasfilm and Disney first announce
plans for a new Star Wars Trilogy fans
were apprehensive that we'd get another
run of prequels thankfully the producers
and director JJ Abrams pulled out all
the stops resulting in one of the best
movies in the entire Saga there's no
question that the force awakens
justifies the hype it appeals to fans
old and new alike the new characters are
all excellent additions to the franchise
the showdown between Han and kylo and
the final lightsaber battle in the woods
are two major standout scenes the major
downside is that much of the characters
and plot of the force awakens parallel A
New Hope especially Rey's Arc and the
Death Star stand-in Starkiller base that
aside it's still an excellent entry into
the Star Wars series with a familiar yet
fresh story and a new cast of faces
ready to take the Saga Forward episode 8
The Last Jedi
director Ryan Johnson definitely didn't
play it safe with his first crack at the
Star Wars saga instead he delivered a
visually stunning and narratively
satisfying film that Echoes the darkness
of The Empire Strikes Back without being
chained to its Legacy although the Last
Jedi has earned almost Universal
critical Acclaim it isn't a perfect
movie some of the subplots could have
done with some trimming down and several
of the more comedic moments were jarring
that said the movie also provides
excellent character development and
absolutely jaw-dropping action scenes
which help make up for its shortcomings
episode 5 The Empire Strikes Back after
the amazing success of A New Hope George
Lucas had a near impossible task ahead
of him when it came to making a sequel
to such a worldwide sensation
fortunately The Empire Strikes Back was
a resounding success darker and more
intense than the original The Empire
Strikes Back suffers only for the lack
of a clear beginning or ending to the
story and even in that regard it's hard
to fault the film The Second Story in a
Trilogy is always the hardest to get
right and for many fans the second
installment was the best regardless The
Empire Strikes Back is an indispensable
film both within the Star Wars universe
and for the science fiction genre as a
whole episode 4 A New Hope with so many
things in life you can't top the
original and that applies even to Star
Wars ever since its theatrical release
four decades ago A New Hope is reign
supreme is the best Star Wars movie this
isn't just Nostalgia talking A New Hope
broke around in so many ways and still
stands up to a critical viewing today
while at its heart A New Hope is a
traditional Underdog tale of good versus
evil the way that George Lucas tells
this story in the framework of a galaxy
far far away made cinematic history
never before had a science fiction film
been approached with the grimy and aged
look that Star Wars had and Lucas's team
brought new model making and
photographic advances to the movie
industry with their work on a New Hope
beyond the historic significance of the
film the original Star Wars is a great
movie in terms of story pacing an action
not only is a new hope the best movie in
the Star Wars franchise it still stands
as one of the best films of all time job
of the Hutt isn't just a Crime Boss as
far as the Star Wars universe is
concerned he is the boss bajaba is so
much more than just a lazy corrupt blob
he's got a history that's just as gross
and bizarre as his slime-coated skin
here are a few things you might not know
about Jabba disillogic cheery
Jabba the Hutt a slimy evolution
Jabba the Hutt is famous for his bulbous
body and slug-like features in the
decades since his debut and Return of
the Jedi he's become a symbol for
gluttony and Corruption and it's all
thanks to his disgusting pulsating bod
but Jabba could have looked very
different in the original Star Wars
script he simply Ambiguously described
big and gross with facial scars from
vicious battles in the original concept
art he's vaguely chewbacca-like and
stands on two legs and in the Marvel
Comics Star Wars adaptation he's a
yellow humanoid with a snout and bushy
mutton chops it was only when Return of
the Jedi entered pre-production that
Jabba started to take his now familiar
form but bringing a giant slug-like
Jabba to life was a major production in
Return of the Jedi there were three main
puppeteers and other performers moved
his eyes and helped animate his tail
Larry Ward who also voiced Greedo
provided the vocals over the years a lot
of people have played Jabba Declan
Mulholland played the first rudely human
job of the Hut in a scene that was
ultimately cut from the original Star
Wars veteran Actor Ed Asner played Jabba
in a radio drama and in the Clone Wars
he's played by Kevin Michael Richardson
several different actors have voiced him
in video games and in The Phantom Menace
he's credited as being played by himself
figure that one out
mommy issues Jabba is a mobster from a
family of mobsters so of course his
family reunions get a little complicated
in 2008 the animated film The Clone Wars
introduced Jabba's Uncle zero the Hutt
and his son the flatulent Rhoda later
the cartoon series expanded jamba's
family tree by bringing in other family
members including the obese Hut
matriarch Mama Jabba's parents don't
play a big on-screen role although they
clearly had an impact on the young Hut
according to the Star Wars character
Encyclopedia one of Jabba's dancers Yana
Del gargan was made in his mother's
image if she seems a little hut-like
that's not an accident as the character
Encyclopedia explains Jabba had Yana's
body enlarged and forces her to wear
makeup that makes her look like his mom
yes it's all a little weird even for
Jabba still Twisted parent kid
relationships are kind of a Star Wars
thing and it wouldn't be the first time
we've seen characters in a galaxy far
far away getting a little too close to
their family members how to speak but
you can't actually learn hatiz because
it's not a real language it is however
based on one on the DVD commentary track
for a New Hope lucasfilm Sound designer
Ben Burt says he based hutis on quechua
a collection of loosely Affiliated South
American languages that date back to
ancient Incan times as The Story Goes
Bert located an instructional tape and
played it for Larry Ward who used the
sounds to create hati's words for Jabba
patisse isn't actually quechua it has no
formal structure not that anyone on set
would have noticed during filming
Jabba's puppeteers delivered all his
lines in English the hatis was added in
post-production and it was designed to
fit Jabba's already filmed mouth
movements your mind Powers will not work
on me boy Dude Looks Like A Lady Hut
physiology is really freaking weird
according to reference books like the
new essential guide to alien species
Huts don't have skeletons although they
do have a mantle that helps give their
heads that distinct Blobby shape they
sweat mucus and they have snake-like
qualities too in the 1995 comic Jabba
the Hutt the dynasty trap Jabba is seen
swallowing an entire human and while
Jabba has a son don't go looking for Mrs
Hut she doesn't exist in Star Wars is
old continuity Huts were born with both
male and female reproductive organs and
could choose to mate with themselves
according to the novelization of Star
Wars the Clone Wars that's exactly what
Jabba did in 2012 though after Disney
purchased lucasfilm The Mouse House
wiped most of Star Wars non-film
continuity clean as part of this
reshuffling the Huts got definitive
genders Jabba's hermaphroditic past is
gone for better or worse he's now a dude
and only a dude tats for Huts Jabba's
arm tattoo wasn't supposed to be
important it was supposed to look cool
in an interview with sci-fi now John
Coppinger the man who sculpted Jabba
said the tattoo was really just a
meaningless afterthought I put a tattoo
onto Jabba's arm as a Finishing Touch
now if you gold Jabba tattoo there
you'll find yards of information about
hati's tribal markings in the novel
Darth Plagueis Jabba's tattoo is implied
to be the symbol of his clan a crime
family known just as much for their
fearsome loyalty as for their greed
their opulent tastes and their fondness
for humanoid women hey at least job is
comfortable in his own gross slimy skin
you can't say that about a lot of people
it doesn't feel the need to be Charming
or anything he's just an unpretentious
very straightforward guy
all right